Welcome to Akihabara!
Say the line, boss.
Oh, come on.
I was just a few minutes late!
I was just a little bit late!
Kept you waiting, huh?
Welcome to Akihabara!
Welcome back, boss!
Miss!
Let's...
hop right...
in...
right...
I thought they used to do that thing where they'd like make you go...
I thought they did the...
Where are the glasses?
Thank you!
Hi.
Hi, Burberry.
Why is it so suspicious?
I'm back!
Yeah!
Oh, that's Google Earth!
Oh, we're in Google Maps.
Otaku glasses where?
Okay, hold on.
Gosh.
Is that better?
They're not...
otaku glasses, though.
They're just regular glasses.
Missing the halo.
TeaTuber, why?
Sorry!
I forgot I had to make my tea.
Yummy!
Hello, everybody.
I was gonna prepare like a whole thing for this.
And then...
I got busy.
So sorry.
I was like, ready to have like a skit and everything.
In my brain.
Not ready on paper.
Ready in my brain.
But, um...
You know.
Actually, it's been several... well, it's several years since I...
since I streamed.
But, a long time ago, I did an Akiba tour.
I think it was for New Year's, actually.
So...
Improv time.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait.
I'm missing a prop.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Wait.
Don't... don't look.
Stop looking.
Um...
Hey!
Where's cool?
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'm all the way back there.
Oh, no!
I'm late for school!
Sorry for running into you!
Earthquake.
Um...
Oh!
You need to go to school too?
Do you go to Love Live Academy?
Just like me?
Oh, it's your first day of class?
Let me show you!
This shirt was $1,000.
I don't have coffee.
What are you...
That's an entire loaf.
I'm a growing girl.
What do you want from me?
You are...
What was special food that you had a craving for?
I don't want to talk about it because...
I couldn't even get it.
Okay?
I'm really depressed about it actually.
So can we move on?
Where are you growing?
Don't... isn't it...
It's so rude to ask a lady her size.
Please.
You're going to V...
Not VTuber Academy.
To the...
To the Love Live Academy too?
Oh my god.
It's insane.
My bread has more physics than I do.
Oooh!
Oh my god.
It's the most jiggly bread in the world.
Why is it so jiggly?
Hahaha.
Okay, I'll fix it.
Okay.
Let's get going!
We're going to be late for class!
Do you know where...
They went to...
Oh wait.
When they went to school in Love Live, it was...
Wait, it was...
The rival school.
Oh shoot.
It wasn't the Love Live girls.
Uh oh, I got it wrong.
Uh oh.
Yeah, A-Rise went here.
Hahaha.
We're late!
Uh...
Just... Oh wait.
No, no.
Turn around.
Google!
This way!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
They're just like me!
Ghost people.
Great bit.
Thanks, Mint.
A real knee slapper.
I knew you would like it.
Run.
Wait.
I'm trapped inside the...
I'm trapped inside the station!
Eh?
This...
How do I get out of the station?
It's already night time, even.
Who put salt around the exit?
Eh?
I wonder what time they took this at.
Oh.
They all think I'm really suspicious, guys.
Oh no.
They're like, Hey, what's this ghost doing over here?
Hey, what's this ghost doing over here?
Why are we in Japan, but we got a Brooklyn accent?
Hey, what's that ghost doing over there with that bread of ours?
That jiggly bread?
Oh.
Don't mind me, officer.
Don't mind me.
Let's just turn around from them.
Okay, let's go back in.
Oh no!
We can't go back!
Remilia?
Wait a second.
What is going on?
What is going on here?
Actually, it says that this was from October 2018, and I'm almost positive I was here.
Because I got...
I have goods from this collab.
And I went to Atore during this collab, so...
This...
One of these is probably me.
I
was in disguise.
Anyways, guys.
You know what?
This is already a little scuffed.
Oh!
It states...
Flan!
Collaboration Event.
Let's just start from here.
Welcome!
To Akihabara!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the birthday gift and...
Kiss cubbies!
Thank you!
Yippie!
So Akihabara actually...
Akihabara station at least has two exits.
This is the electric town gate, as it says here.
And over there...
There's another one all the way down that end.
You can get to Yodobashi more easily.
So...
Total stream when?
When?
I wonder.
That's a good idea.
Wait...
Oh no...
I tried turning off...
Sorry, wait.
Let me see if I can fix something real quick.
So sorry, guys.
I tried turning off the notifs for like the members when they become members through gifted.
Since it kind of clogs up the...
clogs up the notifications a little bit.
But I don't... maybe it didn't work.
Yeah, I turned it off.
But it didn't work.
I'll try it later.
Chat is basically danmaku and you're pretty good at handling that.
So...
Where's the chubby girl's maid cafe at?
Maximum!
I'll get there!
Holy crap, ghosts.
Yeah, these are the ghosts of Akihabara Station.
These are the ghosts of Akihabara Station.
Spooky!
And that...
That's...
Um...
That's the...
See the ghost.
This is where you pay respect.
So yeah, once you leave Electric Town Gate...
Um...
Here's where you can buy your tickets or charge your suika or passimo.
You come here...
Oh!
Scary!
This is...
Katore, right here.
Wow!
Oh my god!
Look, they're all worshipping Remilia!
Ah, Remilia-sama!
Kawaii!
Remilia-sama, kyou mo kawaii!
I'm so glad that this is...
That this is like this.
Um, they do...
Anime collabs here about like every...
Two or three weeks...
I think, so...
Um, it's always rotating...
To different stuff.
Look at them.
Oh!
He's bowing, he's praying.
They're in line to pray!
To Remilia-sama.
But flan is best to who?
How dare you!
Remilia-sama is...
Justice!
It was Bochy the Rock when I was there last.
Oh, I was supposed to be there for Bochy too!
So this is obviously Halloween time because...
Yeah...
Can I get out of here?
Can I escape?
So, if you go out...
If you're facing the gates...
And you go this way...
Out the left side...
How can I change it so it's not night time?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is so old!
They haven't even finished the hotel here yet!
That's crazy!
That's so crazy!
Wait, can I change the year?
How can I change the year?
Um...
Remilia-sama...
Charisma is amazing!
Yes!
I think so too!
Yeah, and it still says Sega!
Eh...
How nostalgic...
How do I change the date?
Hmm...
Hold on...
Let me maybe try going back to...
The map...
And then we're gonna zoom in here...
Maybe it'll give us a different date...
If I come in...
Like right here...
Aha!
July 2022!
Welcome to...
Havara Station!
There we go!
If you ever see these people...
They um...
They often do blood drives in Akiba...
I've never done it before...
Because I'm terrified of needles...
But if you can...
If you can donate the blood...
I recommend!
And now...
The hotel that I talked about...
Is completed...
There's a New Days Konbini right here...
I've actually...
I've never stayed at this hotel before either...
But...
Um...
Yeah you got the Gigo here...
Which is your um...
Which is your arcade...
Used to be Sega as you saw...
Um...
Yeah...
Don't know how much to say about that...
It's kinda sad...
Let's see...
If we go down here...
In here you have a Made Dreamin...
Um...
This is the Heaven's Gate location...
Which if you're going to Made Dreamin...
I recommend this one the most...
Because it's the biggest...
And I think they have the best live stage and stuff like that...
So...
Love Live...
Collaboration Cafe...
Um...
One... Two...
Three... Four...
Five... Six...
Eight... Nine...
Two... Two... Ten?
Hahaha...
Bro thinks she goes here...
But...
I thought there were only nine girls...
Eh?
Hahaha...
Miku is...
I never knew that they had a collab like that...
That's so awesome...
Ahem...
Miku jump scare...
Yeah right?
There's some...
Tourists like...
T-shirt places here...
This is M's...
Which is just a giant...
Sexy store...
You know what I mean...
It's just a giant...
Everything is sexy in here...
It says sexy, sexy store...
Hahaha...
I like the...
I like the standees they have out here...
Sometimes they have a...
Vtuber advertising...
Stuff...
On...
On the television as well...
What does that mean?
Let's go in?
Can we?
No...
What's this though?
...
I don't know what that...
What that is...
I don't know what that's advertising...
Hahaha...
Dangerous building...
It's dangerous...
Hahaha...
Yeah...
It's a bit of...
Let's see...
If you're wanting a hotel that is...
Sorry...
I feel like my tour is going to be all over the place...
If you guys have any specific questions, let me know...
But if you're looking for a hotel...
A good hotel in the Akiba area...
There's this Washington Hotel...
I've stayed here before...
I recommend it...
It's very close...
Of course to the station...
And obviously to everything as well...
So if you need a good hotel...
I recommend...
What's a good hotel?
I'm glad you asked!
If you're looking for a good hotel...
I recommend...
Oh god...
We have to get past...
We can't go past the patchy slot...
The pachinko machine...
Pachinko parlor...
Wait, we're stuck?
We have to go past the pachinko...
Our body is getting sucked into the pachinko...
Where's the McDonald's?
I can show you!
Wait, how do I get back?
What is wrong with Google Maps anymore?
Why am I stuck in certain places?
Did he lose the footage?
What happened?
Well...
I was going to show you over there...
But I guess we can't...
Uh oh, I'm stuck again...
Oh!
Maybe let me try with my mouse instead...
Ah!
I mean not my mouse...
My keyboard...
There it is!
And there's also a Denny's right here...
So...
It's kind of convenient...
To have the hotel...
And then the Denny's...
Mr. Donut Doko...
I'm getting there!
You guys are so impatient!
Oh my gosh, but you guys are just excited...
I get it, me too...
This part of the Akiba station...
There's like a Starbucks...
And there's a Muji...
And there's a GU...
So if you want some more normie kind of stuff...
It's over here...
But down this way...
Meow...
Wow!
The container is still here...
But it's not anymore, unfortunately...
This used to be a store...
Where they would have collab...
Stuff with like...
Different games and anime and stuff like that...
But unfortunately...
It's not anymore...
We'll also go down here...
This will...
I'll lead you all back home, don't worry...
Meow...
Woah!
So here's Yodobashi...
Which is like your big...
Yodobashi camera...
It's your big electronic store...
There's so many floors...
And then up top there's also like...
Lots of restaurants...
There's Tower Records...
There's a Daiso in there...
If you're looking for like...
What's it called?
Yodobashi is huge!
Yeah!
It's so... so big!
This was what Akihabara was originally known for...
Before anime...
It was known for their electronic stuff...
Well... yes...
But more so like the smaller...
Electronic stores, right?
But also in here are a lot of...
Great...
Can we go in there?
No...
In here there's a lot of good little stores...
There's like a crepe store...
There's Jack and the Donuts...
Which I suggest you don't...
There's Takoyaki...
There's...
There's several places...
And then right here is a cat cafe...
Which I've never been to before though...
So...
Yeah...
Now if we...
Turn around...
This is the other side...
This is that other exit I talked about earlier...
So...
What in the donuts?
I think you heard me...
What if Akiba had...
Oh sorry...
I was reading the wrong one...
I was wondering last time you went...
Do you still hear the May Dreaming song play basically everywhere?
Only in one place do I hear...
The May Dreaming song play...
Only in one place...
And I can show you where they still play it...
Top left corner...
See there's a more dates button to switch quickly...
Oh it wasn't there before though...
Oh...
Did I miss it just before?
Also I can't believe I'm backseating Google Maps...
Let's go...
What if Akiba had a waffle house?
That would make it perfect...
To be honest...
If you were asking about the McDonald's...
Here's one of them...
Here's one McDonald's...
That Akiba has to offer you...
But there's actually another one...
What if Akiba got a Wendy's?
Okay that I would be very excited about...
Because...
I actually like First Kitchen very much...
Haha...
But yeah...
You can go in here and get some snacks...
There's also...
If you need to take the Hibiya line...
So this is the JR...
So you're gonna have like...
The Yamanote line and...
Chiyoda line...
And...
All those...
What's the yellow one?
Oh my god...
I can't remember the names anymore...
Jack and the Donut...
Hahaha...
It's delicious...
Chuo!
Thank you...
If you come to Akiba...
And you are taking the Hibiya line...
You will come out...
Over here actually...
So if you're just like...
Wait this doesn't look like the Akihabara...
I saw in Mint's stream...
Actually I wonder if we can get over there...
I wonder...
If we can...
If we can zoom...
Sorry if the zoom is a little...
I'm trying not to go too fast...
To give you a whiplash...
Here!
This is where you'll come out...
The Metro...
So if you just go through this little way...
And then...
Walk walk walk walk...
You'll reach Akiba over here...
Mhmm...
You're running over everyone...
Hahaha... I know...
Um...
But yeah...
We're just gonna focus on the main...
Maybe like...
Well not entirely Chuo Dori...
We'll go to a couple other places too...
So...
You walk walk walk...
What if you come down this way?
I wonder can we go in here?
Can we go in here?
Um...
I think we can...
So if you accidentally...
Don't go out the electric exit gate...
Hey Mint I know you're probably not gonna see this...
But I'm such a big fan...
Oh my gosh...
Thank you...
Yes...
Sometimes you can choose from the main map...
Let's see if it'll let me...
It's like this...
Tiny...
No...
It doesn't look like they filmed in there...
It's okay...
I'm blocking it but...
So if you don't go through the electric town exit...
And you come out the other side...
What if you're like...
Oh gosh I got lost...
And then...
Welcome back Mint...
What is post-pandemic Akiba like?
Chuo Dori has looked like a ghost town lol on Street View recently...
And 99% of doujin stores closed...
What in tarnation is going on there now?
Akiba is crowded as heck...
Maybe in Street View it's very not crowded but...
Oh my gosh...
It's extremely crowded all the time...
Very very often...
So it's definitely not dying...
Which is great...
You're definitely not going to see this...
But I'm a very small fan...
Teeny tiny...
Yeah unfortunately...
Torano Ana did close...
Which is so sad but...
Yeah...
Anyway, you guys let me explain...
If you go through here...
You'll get back to where we saw that...
Made Dreamin...
But also in here...
Is the Square Enix Cafe...
Which they also do like monthly...
Collab stuff...
Last time I was there...
They were doing the Final Fantasy 7 one...
But it was busy every single day...
But certain...
So you like needed a reservation...
But there's also a takeout menu...
Which so you can get takeout stuff...
And also...
There's a store...
Which you can just kind of walk into...
You don't have to have a reservation at the cafe...
And...
But if it's also like...
A not as popular game...
That they're doing...
Or a popular property...
Because sometimes they've done like Fullmetal Alchemist too...
Like a permanent Square Enix Cafe...
Not a pop-up...
Yeah it's permanent...
There's also like some crane games in here...
There's a few...
There's a few restaurants in here as well...
There's actually...
There's actually quite a lot going on in this little small space...
So...
Check it out...
Even though it's just a tiny tunnel...
I'm a ceiling fan...
Wuh wuh wuh wuh wuh wuh...
Wuh wuh wuh...
That's my sound of a ceiling...
Wuh wuh wuh wuh wuh wuh...
There's a restaurant up in here...
Oh...
I don't know what happened...
I've never stayed at this Rem Akiba before...
But...
It might be good...
I don't know...
I'm an average size fan...
Thank you for being...
Thank you for sharing your average-ness...
Uh oh...
I don't usually recommend going to...
Book-offs and stuff...
In super crowded places...
Like Akiba...
But if you're looking for a book-off...
It's over here...
By Danka...
So...
But I've gone in here before...
I've gotten a couple things...
I've been able to find some things...
That are pretty cool...
Thank you...
You're welcome...
And there's also like some...
Other like...
Tourist shops...
But not so many over here...
It's the big...
This is like...
I always...
Sometimes if I come to Akiba...
In the...
In the mornings...
I see a line of people waiting for the...
Pachinko...
Lined up right here...
In the mornings...
It's pretty...
They're ready...
They're ready to pachinko...
You'll definitely see this...
But I'm like one of those fancy modern...
High tech bladeless fans...
Like a Dyson fan...
Wow...
From here you can see Pasera...
We're gonna go down that way now...
So yeah...
This is the tunnel...
That we would've gone through...
If they would've let us...
There's the hotel here...
There's a little...
It says ice cream but it's like...
They have...
They have like...
Yakiimo and stuff like that...
Yummy...
Can I...
If I move over just a tiny bit...
A little...
I went the wrong way...
Wait...
I was gonna see if I could zoom in and see the square...
It's like blocked by the pole though...
But it's on this side...
Mr. Donodoko...
Hold on...
They opened Yostar shop...
Right in front of the station...
Really?
Wait when?
Cause I know there was a Yostar shop at...
In the anime...
Minecraft?
I want to Minecraft so bad...
I want to Minecraft...
I want to play block game...
There's one...
There was a Sega obviously...
But they still do it as Gigo...
Which I'm really happy about...
There's one that does like the themed Tayaki...
I'll show you guys that one...
Later...
But right now the...
The atre is Yuru Yuru...
Yuru Yuru...
Um...
If you go in...
On the second floor...
On the second floor is where you can...
Find whatever pop-up shop...
Is going on...
Last year my cousin was at Akiba...
And I asked him to get a few Konami Famicom games...
At Super Potato...
But they were a bit expensive...
Do you know a place that sells retro games for cheaper?
...
I know another place...
I can't say it's that much cheaper though...
At Akiba...
Because it's like kinda really...
Picked over...
Things are gonna be...
Kind of...
Why is one of the windows empty?
It's actually so sad...
That Akarin is getting...
Blocked by the Momoi Dokei...
...
Momoi Clock...
It's called the Momoi Dokei...
And it's kind of like...
You know...
It's been here for a year...
Like decades...
It's always just been like...
This...
Symbol of Akiba...
And it's...
Block blocked...
Nooo...
Hahahaha...
Yeah the Momoi Clock...
So...
Yeah...
Because Momoi Haruko...
She kind of like...
She would like...
She would have meetings here...
And...
She even has a song about this clock...
Like it's...
It's just...
It got moved before...
It was in a different spot...
I don't remember where...
It got moved a little after they did...
Some construction on the station...
But...
Yeah...
But also as you can see...
Up here they have like a Uniqlo...
The Idolmaster shop is up here too...
The Idolmaster official shop...
Kazpa...
Which if you don't know...
There's several Kazpas in Akiba but...
They also have like...
Oh yeah 3 coins...
If you want a good...
Like...
It's not a 100 yen store...
But it's like 3 coins...
It's like 300 yen...
Everything is really high quality and nice...
Even though most of it is 300 yen...
Momoi Haruko...
Queen of Akiba...
Yeah...
But yeah...
There's also a bookstore up here too...
And...
The Kazpa is selling like...
Recently they've been selling these like...
Last time I went...
I think it was Quintessential Quintuplets...
But it was like little cakes...
And stuff too...
So I thought that was kind of neat...
I didn't grab one but...
You have some...
Other electronic things here...
Wait...
Am I trapped again?
Uh oh...
Forward!
Here we go...
And here...
Can I go back?
This way?
A little more?
No?
Okay...
Here is...
Najiokaikan!
Yeah!
This is like a big...
Mega Otaku...
Building...
There's so many things...
If you want a card shop...
Here... If you want...
They have not only A-Zone...
But they also have...
They also have...
What's the other one called?
Oh my god...
My brain...
The ones that do doll fees...
The ones that...
VULKS!
Thank you!
They have VULKS as well...
They actually closed the Cospo and Atore one...
What?
That must have been very recent...
Really?
I think they are opening a Love Live shop down the hall from the iMath store where the Cospo used to be...
Wait but they were right next to each other...
The Cospo and the...
The Cospo and the Idolmaster store were right next to each other...
Are you sure?
What?
How soon did that happen?
That must be very very recently...
I didn't see it last month...
Did you show Mandarake?
Mandrake?
No I haven't... We haven't gotten down there yet...
But yeah...
So this is like...
Everything...
There's also... Right here is a cute little gift...
It says gift shop...
Like a good...
Omiyage...
Presents!
Souvenirs!
Souvenirs...
Yeah...
So I definitely recommend...
You could spend forever here...
There's K-Books... There's AmiAmi...
Like I said there's...
There's a card shop...
There's just regular figure places...
There's...
There's like an airsoft place too...
So...
Lots and lots of stuff...
And of course there are big Uma Musume...
Billboard right here...
And then they play like...
Ads and stuff here...
Which is kind of fun to see...
Look at this... This view is so...
Akihabara right?
Yeah...
Let's see... This is Pachinko...
In case you were like...
Wow Railgun...
Madoka... Evangelion...
It's just Pachinko...
Pachinko...
Oh my god... This is...
So funny... Do you...
For people... Don't say if you know what this store is...
But do you wanna guess what this...
What this line is for?
Oh my gosh... This is so funny...
Because it even looks kind of early in the day...
Because there's not so many people...
So there's already people...
Lining up for this...
Crepes... Okay good... Figures...
Ramen...
Mmm...
Cards... Mmm...
Yeah like some of the stores aren't even open...
Like here's another card store...
Pancakes... Oh good guess...
This is for Ensemble Stars...
As you can see this is the Ensemble Stars store...
And so...
In the past...
You used to have a...
You used to need a reservation to get in...
But I think nowadays you can just kind of go...
But this screen right here is always...
Playing Ensemble Stars...
So these people are up early in the morning...
For On Stars...
But it's right here...
Right... I think it's...
I think it's this one...
But it's right...
In the same building as Gamers...
Which is...
Of course an iconic store...
In Akihabara...
This is you know...
Dejico from Digicara and everything...
So the line is for pretty boys...
Yeah...
Look at them... Look at them...
They're so excited to get their merch...
Hahahaha...
Um...
And...
What is this?
Tsubaki...
I actually don't know...
Sorry... I'm a fake fan...
Kunoichi Tsubaki...
Mmm...
Forehead anime...
Yeah I can tell...
Why does it look like Takagi-san?
Is it the same artist?
She looks like Takagi-san...
And forehead...
Hahahaha...
Oh it is the same artist...
I've never seen it though...
But sometimes they do...
Say there's a new single coming out...
For an anime...
They will...
Typically the singer...
Will have an event...
At Gamers on the top floor...
And they do other collaboration stuff too...
Sometimes if a concert was released...
If you go...
And go shopping... You can see the...
Say the costume...
That the idol wore...
Or the seiyuu wore...
At the concert...
So it's still fun to stop by...
I like to go in there and check out what's kinda new sometimes...
So earlier...
Someone asked...
Where can you still hear the made dreaming theme song played in Akiba?
And it's this one!
This one is always playing...
The made dreaming theme song...
So...
If you walk by here...
You'll definitely hear it...
My long lost Oshii...
Used to do regular shows up there...
Wait who was it?
Who was it?
24 hour soba huh?
Yes!
This is Fujisoba!
Which is a chain actually...
But they are 24 hours...
So if you're in Akiba...
Maybe you are staying here in a hotel or something...
And you're like... Oh my gosh...
I'm hungry but I don't want konbini food...
There is a Fujisoba here...
That is 24 hours so...
And it's a chain...
So if you're somewhere else and you're like...
Oh Fujisoba...
Someone from Soundora...
Don't want to go into it...
Understandable...
Yeah...
But...
They don't just have soba...
I think they have other stuff too...
Curry and things like that...
And they do take out...
This place right here...
Used to be the Volks building...
Used to be just a bunch of...
This one is really depressing...
To explain...
It used to be the Volks building...
And it used to have...
Like a bunch of...
Anime figure shops and...
Collab stores and things like that...
Unfortunately...
That's not the case anymore...
But...
It was empty for years...
It was empty for a very long time...
Until recently...
Until very recently...
Where...
It is now a drug store...
So it's not empty anymore...
At least...
Because it was really depressing walking by it...
And it just being all boarded up...
And nothing going on...
But...
It's now a drug store...
So it's a little depressing...
Umm...
But...
Yeah...
And by drug store I mean like...
You can get medicine...
And things...
I love drugs!
Legal or illegal?
I'm sorry...
Yeah...
I'm a drug addict now...
There's one right over here!
There's a Matsukiyo!
Right there!
You don't need another drug store...
I'm sorry...
Over here...
Maybe...
Hold on...
Maybe if I go out a little bit more...
We transported back to 2013!
Oh my gosh!
You can see it...
It was so...
Yes!
Wait...
I was like...
Wait, where am I right now?
We transported...
Wait, see more dates...
July 2022...
There we go...
Sorry, I'm trying to keep this as updated as possible for now...
So that way...
I can give a more authentic...
A more accurate tour, right?
Time travel...
Can you see the Sega building from here?
You mean the GIGO?
Yes...
Yeah, the GIGO is right there...
Down here...
Now we're in 2017!
Now we're in 2015!
We're back in 2015!
Can I change the date again?
Oh wait!
We have September 2023!
Oh my gosh, so recent!
You have another GIGO down here...
You have a LAMTARO here...
Which is like...
Part Yabai store...
Part...
Um...
Like other stuff...
It's just like a variety of stuff...
But it's a little...
Little Yabai...
At the LAMTARO...
Very interesting at the top floors...
But yeah, it's a little...
All stores Yabai...
Part Yabai...
Maybe mostly Yabai...
But what I wanted to point out here was the Pepper Lunch...
Because I really like Pepper Lunch...
Pepper Lunch...
Right here...
This used to be the only Pepper Lunch in Akiba...
But they recently...
Also opened another one...
All the way...
Down there...
But it's much bigger...
This one is really small...
So if you're craving Pepper Lunch...
Pepper Ranch...
What does it add here?
I don't recognize it though...
I'm such a fake fan...
My gosh...
Sorry, I don't know anything...
I don't even know Akiba...
Oh, it's both...
Oh, it's Bochy the Rock...
I obviously know Bochy...
Wait, you were being serious...
I thought you were kidding and being like...
What are you talking about?
That's Bochy the Rock, obviously...
Actually, this is your lie in April...
There's actual Bochy...
And the gamers...
I like this place...
It turned into a...
That's right...
I forgot it turned into a trading card place...
But it used to be kind of like a pop-up store...
And sometimes there would be like...
There's another one...
There's another place that does this in Akiba...
But it...
Used to be like...
One time it was a pop-up store for like...
Seiyuu branded headphones...
So like if you're just like...
Oh, I want Ogura Yui to speak in my ear...
You can...
You could get that...
But there's another place like that...
Um...
Last time I went...
They were selling iCuts...
Headphones...
But now it's trading card...
Okay...
I don't even think I'm ready to talk about it...
Over here...
Hey, get out of my way...
Get out of my way...
I'm so too...
Imagine an anime about someone trapped in Akiba...
Who keeps getting transported to different ears as they walk around...
That would be actually so awesome...
Right here is Mansei-bashi...
Mansei-bashi bridge...
Which is just...
Iconic bridge in Akiba...
Um...
You have the train that runs here...
Um, you have some restaurants here...
Um, you have just a really beautiful view...
Of Akiba here...
Uh...
This used to be a famous... famous katsu place, but it's now...
Not just katsu, like a famous... it's just like a famous... how do I say?
Meat?
I'm so depressed about it.
But... I believe they opened like a... not... I mean obviously this doesn't exist anymore, but they opened a smaller scale store with sandwiches.
From what I understand.
So...
Yeah...
Had the meats.
They did have katsu sando though.
They did have like...
Some... they had like a store down here where you could get some stuff and then the restaurant obviously.
Akiba is changing.
But also, so much of Akiba is still the same.
So... it's not so bad.
It's bad, but not so bad.
Which way should we go down?
Do I want to go down Chuo Dori first or...
No, we can go down here.
So over here...
Right here is where you find the Grand Blue Fantasy Cafe.
It's... if you see the Pase La... wait.
You can't really... hold on.
I think I showed it earlier.
You can see it from over here too.
Come on, tree!
Here, here, here.
The Pase La...
The Pase La Resort?
This is also...
Not just a pop-up.
But I believe they also do other cafe pop-ups as well.
Like one time they had... Oh, here you can see... What is that?
Is
that Kochi Usa?
Am I dumb?
It is Kochi Usa?
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait.
I don't want to be...
I don't want to say it and be wrong.
But yeah, they do other pop-ups in here.
It's definitely worth checking out what they're doing.
Because I believe also this is the Monster Hunter place too.
So there's like... there's a lot going on here all the time.
So it's the Monster Hunter Cafe, the Grand Blue Cafe, and then what other pop-up cafes as well.
Oh, see.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Monster Hunter on the third floor.
So yes.
There's also...
Pasella is a karaoke place.
It's like a chain.
A chain karaoke one.
And it's not...
This isn't even the only one in Akiba.
But they are known for their toast boxes.
These.
They're so yummy.
So, so good.
The Toast Cafe.
Yeah, yeah.
You can get them.
You can order them while you're like...
While you're singing.
But this is not just...
It says like famous dessert in Akiba.
That's a lie.
You can get the honey toast at any Pasella.
Maybe they do specialized ones here.
But like you can get the honey toast anywhere.
And what it is, is it's like...
It's...
It's like four pieces of toast that make a box.
And then they put like ice cream and fruit and stuff inside the box.
Inside the...
Inside the toast.
So it's really yummy.
And...
Also here is a theater called Parms.
Which is a...
Event...
It's basically just a live...
It's like a theater.
Not a live house.
It's a theater.
Which...
This group called Kamen Joshi.
They play there every day.
So if you wanna go see some idols.
And you're just like...
Well...
I don't know where to go.
You can always come here.
And they will be doing a live show.
So it's pretty fun.
Every day.
This is some collab cafe.
But I can't read it.
I have no idea what...
E...
Eor...
Eorzia?
I can't read it.
I saw it down here too.
Cafe...
All I can see is cafe.
A Final Fantasy XIV...
Eorzia's Final Fantasy XIV...
Thanks guys.
Oh my gosh.
How...
She's not even qualified to give this tour.
Why is she even giving us the tour right now?
She doesn't even know...
She doesn't even go here.
If you come down this way a little bit too.
This is crazy.
If you are a fan...
Whoa...
If you are a fan of Love Live!
Which may be these guys are too.
This is actually...
One of the parks that they visit in Love Live.
Why are there such...
Why are there?
Why is there such a big group of...
I say park, but there's like just a couple benches in here.
Why is there...
Why is there such a big group of people?
People!
What's going on?
Those are definitely love livers.
It almost looks like this guy has some anime...
Maybe it's Oshii.
When was this taken?
September 2023?
If you were there in September 2023, I'm so...
Is that you?
I'm just so... What is going on?
I'm so curious.
In store meow.
Let's see.
I'm trying to decide how I want to go about this.
There's some other stuff back there.
I know that's like the most vague phrasing ever.
We won't go down this street yet.
Let's go back to Chuo Dori.
Wasn't one where Nico's apartment got torn down and made into a park?
No!
This park was already there.
They sit in it in Love Live!
In that park.
Like in the original Love Live!
But I don't actually know where Nico's apartment was.
I'll be honest.
I actually don't know.
Yay!
Akihabara!
Akihabara.
This main street here...
This street that goes down here is called Chuo Dori.
Like I said, the main street.
So if we go down a little here...
This is where we started.
I'm just gonna go down a little bit.
This is Akiba station down here.
Just to get you a little bit oriented.
There's that hotel.
There's Radio Kaikan.
There's gamers.
There's the main dream in.
So...
This is all that.
If you turn around here...
You have...
Let me move that a little bit.
You have Onoden.
Which is like a famous...
Onoden has been here forever as well in Akihabara.
It's one of those like staple electronic stores that has been here forever.
And...
But...
In the Onoden building...
There's a book off.
Oh no, sorry.
The book off is the one that I...
Pointed out earlier.
There is...
Oh my gosh.
There is a cos-pa.
There is...
There is a cosplay store.
What else is there?
I'm trying to remember.
I think this is where...
I think it was a pop-up store though.
I couldn't remember.
But they did have like a blue archive.
No.
Not a blue archive.
I'm thinking of somewhere else.
They had a...
They had just like a general doujin artist pop-up.
Which I didn't get to go to.
I was busy.
I was in a hurry.
And I didn't get to go.
Is that...
Touhou?
Yes.
But there's like a Touhou corner...
In the store.
I'm the worst at describing stuff.
One thing I do want to point out here.
That I like to come here for though.
Is the Cure Maid Cafe.
Which if you're wanting a maid cafe.
That's not like your super high energy maid cafe.
Just one...
It doesn't even have a table charge.
It's very relaxed and chill.
It's the Cure Maid Cafe.
They are always doing a collaboration with some sort of anime or game.
So...
Before you go, I would check the schedule.
Because...
You know...
Something...
Stop!
Stop looking over here!
Stop looking!
No, no, no!
Take us to B1.
What?
You'll never go to the second floor!
You'll never go!
You'll never go there!
Why do you think it's only one floor and men's goods is two floors?
Actually, I'll also never go there.
Because I'm not allowed, I think.
I don't think I'm allowed on these floors.
I think it's only for guys to go to.
Which makes me even more curious.
I want to go even more now.
Costume lingerie?
Oh, yeah.
I mean, you can get that at like Don Quixote too and stuff like...
They sometimes sell like really sexy costumes and...
I'll be honest.
I've been in M's but I've never been in Love Mercy because I'm shy.
I've been in M's before.
Love Mercy has been here forever.
It's also like one of those stores that's just been here in Akiba forever but...
I've never gone because I'm...
I'm shy.
Okay?
But I went to M's.
I don't know.
Maybe because I went with some friends.
Love Mercy is the same as M's though.
Yeah, but I went with friends before.
Anyways, let me continue my wholesome talking about the Cure Maid Cafe.
Oh, this is it.
Right here.
Basically, you'll go up the escalator a couple times.
A couple floors.
And you'll arrive on one floor and...
Thank you.
What do you mean cute?
What do you mean?
The?
The floor with the...
With the maid cafe has...
Stop it!
It has... Stop it right now!
Do you want this tour or not?
Huh?
Oh my god.
Thank you for that good suba!
Loving the updated Akiba tour.
Your original stream was what got me hooked on your channel in the first place.
Glad you're back.
Thank you!
I hope one day I could...
Well, you know, not myself walking around in Akiba.
But if someone walked around, Akiba went for me.
And I got to talk about it and stuff on stream.
I hope one day I can do something like that.
It'd be really fun.
I think.
Oh, what was I saying?
Oh!
You go here!
On your... You go up the escalator a couple floors.
In front of you, on the right, will be Kiramei Cafe.
Across from it will be the Kazpa.
To the left of it will be an extension of the Kazpa.
It's like a different store also.
It's kind of confusing.
And through there is also the cosplay store.
Let's get out of here!
Mina Lenski Cafe!
Yes!
Oh, yes!
Thank you!
Yes, this cafe...
The cafe... Kir Cafe is the cafe that Kotori worked at in Love Live!
So it's also a...
You can also get like...
Love Live...
Kir Made Goods...
There as well.
Wolfman!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
Chat broke?
Yeah, you did break!
You helped inspire me to push through and get my game on Steam!
Oh my gosh!
Entire journey has been heckin' awesome and I love popping into streams!
Fight me!
Okay, I'll fight you!
Congrats!
I'm broken...
Let's see...
Matsukiyo is a chain.
It's nothing special.
It's not Akiba special or anything.
It's just a drugstore.
And you can get skincare there.
Here's like if you're looking for...
Oh, I didn't point them out over there either.
But if you're looking for some of like those small electronic stores...
That are like very, you know...
Like original Akihabara.
Lots in there.
One thing, one place I do want to point out over here...
As you can see from the sign...
This is a maid cafe I really like.
The Isekai Maid Cafe.
I like this cosplayer.
Her name is Shiyo.
She's very cute.
AskGosu!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
But if you want to go to the...
Isekai Maid Cafe...
The entrance is right here.
And it's just right here.
On the second floor.
Right here.
So...
Yeah, it's on the second floor.
It's very cute.
I like the theme there.
Oh, oh wait!
Yeah, here they are.
The...
The other electronic stores and stuff like that.
Lots in this building in general.
So...
Um...
Oh my gosh, so cute!
The yuri yuri!
So cute!
This is the other side of Akiba Station.
So if you come out the other way...
Can we walk this way?
Woah, woah, woah.
For real?
Can we walk this way for real?
Will it let us in?
Will we be transported to night time?
With all the guys standing around?
Okay, we're going.
Wait, is it...
It's Idol Master now?
Hahaha!
And...
La plus...
La plus sama?
What is that?
Um...
Is it like...
Shadowverse or something?
What is that?
Oh...
Yes it is.
Hahaha!
Um...
What's so funny is...
So yeah, see?
We're back at Akiba Station!
Woohoo!
It's so funny.
These...
These advertisements for like...
Oh gosh.
Every time that I've gone back to Akiba...
There are Arknights here but...
Um...
Right now, they're usually Blue Archive advertisements so...
I guess...
I guess Blue Archive took over.
But this is the other side.
Oh, remember when we were trying to go to school?
This is...
The UDX building.
It's the school that the girls...
The rival girls go to in Love Live.
There's a bunch of restaurants and stuff in there.
Um...
Over here is the Tamashii Nation store which...
I recommend checking out 100% because they sometimes...
Um...
Although they'll have like...
How do I describe it?
It's not like a pop-up.
It's like almost...
It almost feels like a museum.
Like they'll have like a...
Like sometimes it'll be...
Um...
Like an exhibit of...
Macross.
And it'll show like a bunch of their old Macross figures and...
The...
Um...
Timeline of Macross and stuff like that.
And things like that.
So...
Um...
They'll have like...
Like one time I went and there was the...
Um...
That costume that guy wears.
I can't remember anything today.
I'm so sorry, guys.
And it's like...
It's like the black straps across his body.
Um...
Rip the Gundam Cafe.
Yeah.
I know.
Unfortunately, the Gundam Cafe and the AKB48 Cafe used to be here.
They're no longer here.
It is now the Tamashii Nation store.
Um...
Hot Limit!
Thank you, Ghost Talker.
Yes, TM Revolution.
They had the costume.
Um...
They had the TM Revolution...
Like the Hot Limit song costume there.
So it was...
Uh...
I was just like...
Whoa.
I'm pretty sure I have a...
A picture somewhere.
There's a coffee.
There's a coffee cafe.
Yeah.
And then, there's also a revolving sushi place that has been here...
Forever.
Um...
It's very small.
But if you are, like...
There's a sushi dough...
Like...
Right over here...
Um...
And a Hamazushi.
Wait.
Is that still there?
The Hamazushi?
Actually, I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
But if you're wanting a sushi place...
And those...
Um...
The sushi dough...
And maybe the Hamazushi are busy...
There's also a sushi place that's a rotating sushi...
Right there!
So...
The atre...
Oh yeah, here... there's the Sushiro.
It's kinda in the basement, right?
Oh, wait, where'd it go?
Is it over here?
Oh, there it is!
Yeah, it's in the basement, so...
Let's go to another drugstore.
They're everywhere, the drugstores.
Why are Japanese people...
Wait...
Because I'm an otaku.
Gigo here.
This one has like...
I'm pretty sure it's this one.
I don't think the other ones have it as much.
But this one has like the Gundam.
Pods, if I remember correctly.
I don't...
You can correct me if I'm wrong about that.
But...
The Gundam Tide Pods, exactly.
Let's actually go down here.
Because this is the Gigo I mentioned earlier.
How...
It is this road, right?
Hold on.
Let me get my bearings.
Yes!
It's right here.
It's not open right now.
But this is where they do...
You can kind of see it.
Is that it?
Actually, no.
I think that's a reflection of KFC.
Never mind.
Wait...
It says KFC.
But the sign...
Is it reflecting this one?
It's reflecting KFC.
But this is not the KFC.
That's kind of confusing.
This is where they do the Taiyaki.
Is what I was trying to say.
So it's like themed Taiyaki.
Which is kind of fun.
So it like...
I'm trying to think of what it was.
It's been Love Live before.
It's been...
One week since you looked at me.
They have Hololive 5th Gen right now.
Oh, really?
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Sega's Taiyaki.
Unfortunately, now it's Gigo's Taiyaki.
Yes, they did do Sonic before.
That was the other one I was thinking of.
So...
You can get some Taiyaki here.
I remember the Persona 3 one.
And Beast Ball.
I don't know if the Vspo...
The Taiyaki was Vspo.
But yeah...
There's an anime...
An anime song cafe here.
Called Guild.
I know friends that have been.
I personally have not.
So I can't tell you how it works.
There's just hobby shops everywhere.
I haven't been everywhere.
So I'm so sorry.
I'm a fake fan.
Not qualified to give this tour.
But...
There's actually several anime song cafes and bars in Akiba.
Another called Alchemist.
Which is closer to Yodobashi Camera.
Actually.
That one's Alchemist.
What was the other one?
It was another one that I also haven't been to before.
But my friend recommended it.
So I'm gonna go next time.
I can't remember it though.
How dare the tour guide has not been into literally every store.
Also this Gigo the last time I came.
It might be new.
Or it might have been a one time thing.
But I think they do...
There's crane games on these floors.
And then on the top floor there was an event space.
Where they had a Steins Gate...
A Steins Gate collab.
Where they had a Steins Gate collab.
And they had like little standees.
And they had exclusive merch.
And I got this super duper cute block calendar.
That I have on my desk now.
It's so cute.
So it's sad that it's not Sega anymore.
But you know Gigo is doing well.
And I can appreciate that.
It feels almost like Sega never left.
Almost.
Because they're still at it.
They're still at it.
Even though it's so sad.
And there's a KFC here.
If you are craving the Kentucky Fried Chicken.
It's here.
Here you can get a...
I was gonna say you can get some...
Some visual novels here.
Lots of visual novels there.
TV game.
I love TV game.
Now this street down here.
Is what...
Um...
My friends and I like to call Nugget Bridge.
Because...
It is so packed with...
Maids.
Every night.
Down this street.
It's so packed with maids.
There will be maids...
Trying to stop you at every...
At every stop.
They'll be like...
Do you wanna come to our maid cafe?
How does a ninja girl maid cafe sound?
Do you wanna come to our maid?
Right here?
I don't know if they do it so much anymore.
But this is where...
This is where one of the maid dreaming locations is.
And sometimes the girls will...
Like I said I don't know if they do it so much anymore.
But they used to come out onto this little...
Onto this little balcony and like...
Dance and like...
Kind of try and...
Entice people from above.
Like a real angel.
Ninja maid girls...
Yeah you get so many different kinds of girls here.
It's like...
I've seen a military type girl.
I've seen a ninja girl.
I've seen...
My
mind is blank.
Did we find the ninja girl?
The chubby girl maid cafe yet?
No I'll take you there.
I'll take you there.
Don't worry.
Patience.
I think...
When I was...
When we watched...
Some time ago we watched...
A couple streams ago we watched the opening...
For the Akiba maid war anime.
I'm pretty sure...
This is what the street that I think it was.
Cause like I said...
I think this is the one that it's supposed to be.
I might be wrong though.
But I think this is the one.
I was like...
Wait a second.
But also Melon Books!
On Melon Books the entrance is actually...
On the other side.
You can go through...
This is an arcade.
You can cut through it.
Or you can just walk around here.
I'll show you.
But Akiba...
Akiba are also...
All over Akiba.
They're electronic stores.
They have really cheap electronic stuff.
You can see the balcony here.
It's very cute.
And here we have a Kotobukiya.
Yahoo!
Kotobukiya is so...
So great.
Why is everything closed?
How early did they film this?
I wonder.
Um...
The Kotobukiya on the first floor.
You can get like...
Final Fantasy stuff.
Um...
There's a little bit of Hololive stuff.
There's a big Nijisanji section.
On the second floor there's...
What I really love about Kotobukiya...
Is getting the stuff for storing my figures.
Um...
It's like...
Oh yeah!
The Tales of stuff.
Though the Tales of...
They used to have a really dedicated Tales of section.
I don't think that is around anymore.
Um...
All the Vtuber stuff on the third floor now.
Oh really?
That must have been...
Actually I don't think I went the last time I...
Oh yeah there...
Remember how I said places in Akiba...
Or places in Japan open late and close early?
Opens at 12?
And then opens...
I mean closes...
Probably at like 7.
Gosh it's so early.
It opens so late.
Hololive on the top floor.
Thanks for letting me know.
It drives me mad.
Me too.
It's so frustrating.
Because of course...
You're wanting to make the most out of your day.
And visit the most places as possible.
But it kind of makes it hard...
When they don't open until noon.
Um...
But yeah.
I like to get the stuff...
Like um...
Like they have the standees for your figures.
They have like um...
Acrylic boxes and stuff.
For storing your figures.
They got a lot of stuff in here.
I really like it.
They got stuff for model kits and everything like that.
Paints and...
I mean they're not the only place of course.
Oh excuse me.
They're not the only place of course but um...
Sorry just going back to the main road real quick.
If you go in through here.
This is where Melon Books is.
Um...
You'll pass some crane games on the right.
And there's a couple of gacha...
Gachapon that always steal your money.
Melon Books!
Fix your gachapon please!
I had to... I tried.
Oh my god I tried helping some poor guy.
Who...
Who got his money stuck in the gachapon.
And...
It happened to me and my friends some time ago too.
And like we kind of like just...
BAM!
On the gacha a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Um and it eventually came out.
And they're not like super cheap either.
They're like 400 yen.
They were like some blue archive uh...
Keychain like little acrylic...
Acrylic keys and I was just like...
I was like trying to help the guy.
I was just like...
Uh... I was like...
Here let me try.
This thing has eaten my money before too.
And I was like...
I was like...
But it was like...
When it happened to me before it was kind of late at night.
So there weren't so many people around.
So we were like...
Okay with like kind of...
Hitting the...
Maybe it's broken because so many people keep hitting it.
Because it keeps...
Eating their money!
But anyway do not use the gachapon there.
Because it's actual gacha.
You might just get nothing.
So...
Don't do it!
Even if you...
See the blue archive or the genshin impact.
Don't do it!
In the end I couldn't even help the guy.
I was like I'm so sorry.
I can't get it out.
He was like it's okay.
But I really tried to help him out.
Sorry guy.
Nah I'd still do it.
Last order films.
Thank you for the 20 gifts.
Thank you.
But yeah.
So if you're tempted.
I recommend not to be tempted.
Don't even look that way.
Sorry but we keep skipping some stuff.
Because I'm going everywhere.
This is the gigo.
Just to get you guys up to speed.
There's the isekai maid cafe.
Over there is the train station.
There's an arcade here.
Mansei-bashi bridge down there.
Yeah.
Ramen shop here.
More game store stuff here.
Another tamashii nation store here.
It's smaller.
I just recommend going to the tamashii nation's bigger place.
This place is always.
There's always so many.
This is one of those like stores that.
Like the tour.
The foreigner tour groups.
You know.
Just go on.
And so like.
There's always so many people.
Because they meet up here you know.
Yeah it's a tourist trap.
It's one of those tourist traps that.
Somehow made it through the pandemic.
But yeah.
So if you go through here.
Oh wait it's open now.
Oh you can see.
If you go here.
Like I said the gachapon will be on the right.
There will be a stairs down.
Into melon books.
And then there's some stairs up into.
The uh.
Into.
The arcade that is right here.
So it's all connected.
It's kind of nice.
Hey.
Why are we saying hey?
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you.
Oh.
Hey.
Pour one out for me.
I found the Namco Noir clone arcade cabinet.
At an amazing price locally.
But I measured it and it won't fit through my door.
Time to get rid of the door.
I don't know what else to tell you.
Mmm.
Yum.
Here's Akiba Culture Zone.
But also.
Someone mentioned it earlier.
Here's Super Potato.
The.
It's like you know.
One of the.
It was the retro store until it kind of like got.
It's still fun to visit though.
You know.
Even though some things become like a little overrun.
They're still very fun to visit.
You know it's still fun to see the history.
But if you're going.
Be prepared.
Because the stairs are very steep.
And very small.
And inside the store too.
I mean inside of a lot of stores in Japan.
It's just very very very jam packed.
And crowded.
Like even when there's not a lot of people.
It's just so.
It's so tiny in there.
Um.
But on the third.
Floor?
Third floor?
Fourth floor?
Is where they have Snake.
And I go there every time.
I'm back in Japan.
And I take a picture with him.
I take a picture with Snake.
Every time.
I often go there to buy candy.
Is Snake for sale?
No.
So sad.
He's not.
I never even noticed the candy.
I just go there to see Snake.
Cute.
Candy.
Here is.
Akiba.
Wait.
What date is it?
Wait a second.
2022?
But Backstage Pass was already.
Backstage Pass was already closed by then.
Maybe they just didn't get rid of the sign.
This is Akiba Culture Zone.
Which.
I'll show you from the back here.
Real quick.
They have a ton of stores in here.
This is where all the maids will try to bombard you.
Hey come to my cafe.
Hey how does this cafe sound?
Hey how does that cafe sound?
Trying to get a good view of Culture Zone real quick.
Hold on.
Maybe here?
This is good.
Hahaha.
Um.
So Culture Zone.
Is this big building.
It's really awesome.
Um.
The first floor is Dashinban.
Oh no sorry.
I think the first floor is also Dashinban though.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
First and second floor are Dashinban.
The first floor is more like regular anime goods.
And then the second floor is like doujin.
And a little bit more yabai stuff.
Hahaha.
Chuuu.
Thank you.
Still not as much as an overpriced scam as Mashakusou.
Maybe.
Who knows.
But um yeah you can get figures.
Like you know.
I say anime goods.
There's like Vtuber stuff down here too.
But the more yabai stuff is on the second floor.
If you're looking for that.
Um the third floor is like a mishmash of a ton of different stores.
Um.
You have like the Trio is an idol store.
Which I like to go frequent.
Um.
You have card shops.
You have figure shops.
You have a lot of different kind of stuff.
Same on the fourth floor.
Um.
The fifth floor is an at home cafe.
One of them in Akihabara.
There's actually.
There's this one.
There's a building of at homes.
Right over here.
And then there's one at Don Quixote.
I.
Honestly.
This one is the biggest.
And the nicest.
I believe because it's the newest.
But um.
What's at home cafe?
It's a maid cafe.
I've been to this at home.
How long.
How long of a wait.
Did you wait for?
Because.
What's itube studio?
I'll get to that one second.
Um.
Because this at home cafe.
I've tried going so many times.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I've been.
I've tried to go to this at home cafe.
Several times now.
Several times.
But.
The wait has always been like two hours.
It is ridiculous.
I went to the one over here.
Which is also seven floors.
And.
The wait there was about an hour and a half.
Actually no.
It was more like an hour.
Yeah.
But it was still very very very long time.
Um.
Which we probably should have done a reservation.
But.
We just didn't.
Um.
Yeah.
How long is the wait for cure made?
Like zero minutes.
You can usually just.
I've never had a wait.
I've always just been able to walk up.
Frog welcome to membership.
Thank you.
But yeah.
So.
You know.
At home cafe.
I would recommend probably going to the Don Quixote one.
Because that one seems to always have the smallest line.
For.
If you're wanting to wait.
Um.
But it's also I'm pretty sure also pretty small.
I've been there like just a handful of times.
Um.
And I'll show you Don Quixote later.
Uh.
The one in Akiba.
Um.
Since it's so packed.
Is it expensive?
It's really just high quality.
Like um.
The kind of experience that you get.
Is really high quality.
So.
Um.
You know it's really popular with guys and girls.
With like all sorts of people.
And then of course.
Because it's like one of the more popular made cafes.
It's also very popular with foreigners.
So.
You just get like a ton of people going there all the time.
Um.
If you go to at home cafe.
Prepare to wait.
Unless you do a reservation.
Um.
But is high quality good for made cafes?
I think it depends on.
What kind of.
Experience you want.
At the top here.
Is this place called iTunes Studio.
Um.
It used to be an idol cafe.
That I actually auditioned for.
Called Backstage Pass.
Which I made it into.
But then I turned it down.
Because I wanted to focus more on my studies.
Um.
But now as you can see here.
The sign was over here.
Meow.
Right here.
This was Backstage Pass.
This is Horiyuchi Kaori.
Um.
Oh gosh.
What was her name?
They don't have my Oshii.
Oh there's um.
There's Moyazu.
She's a really popular um.
She's a really popular.
Mukbang YouTuber.
She eats so much food.
Um.
Oh my gosh.
What was your name?
Was it Yui?
I don't remember.
But yeah.
They don't have my Oshii up here.
But that's okay.
I think she had already graduated.
So it was this um.
At the cafe.
It was actually produced by the same person.
That produced uh.
Does she eat shiroko?
She has.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
She has.
She did a video recently.
You mean shirako?
No.
Wait.
Shiroko.
Shiroko from.
No.
Don't eat shiroko from Blue Archive.
Shiroko.
What was I saying?
Oh.
Um.
It was produced by the same person.
That produced uh.
It was Morning Musume.
Tsunku and Hello Project.
So um.
Their songs were very.
Pretty uh.
What's the word?
Like Hello Project like.
And um.
Unfortunately it's closed now.
Which is so sad.
Because I would visit very often.
And it turned into this.
iTube Studio.
Which was like.
Amalgamation of backstage.
And iTube Studio.
Which was just a cafe.
Of YouTubers.
I never went.
Because I was so confused by it.
I did not understand.
It was just a cafe.
Where you can go and talk to YouTubers.
Or girls that were wanting to be.
Popular YouTubers.
It was very weird.
And the inside of the cafe.
Used to be so iconic for backstage.
And then they like tore it all apart.
For this ugly like.
It looked like a Mac store.
But iTube Studio.
Has also since shut down.
So.
So we don't even have.
I don't know.
What will pop up there next.
I'll be on the lookout.
I suppose.
You were telling us.
About how you're cute enough.
To get accepted into an idol group.
No.
Oh my gosh.
My audition for it was so.
It was so embarrassing.
I.
They actually had it.
Not at the cafe itself.
It was like at some.
Separate building.
Which.
I might be able to find.
Probably not though.
It was a long time ago.
But I went.
And.
The guy.
Was like interviewing some of us.
He was just like wow.
A foreigner.
And I was just like yeah haha.
And he was like asking me how I got into backstage.
And stuff like that.
I had seen them at an idol show.
And really started to like them.
But.
I also did like some dance covers.
Of some backstage songs.
So they were like whoa.
Whoa.
She really likes.
She's already.
She already knows the choreography.
So I showed him that.
And.
Then they took us.
He was like showing the other people though.
My videos and I was really embarrassed.
But.
Then we go to the.
To the.
To the actual like.
Audition part.
Which was three people sitting in a.
Dance studio.
Like you know there was the mirrored walls and everything.
And we sat along the wall.
And they called us up one by one.
And they asked us to sing something.
And I was like.
I was like okay.
And I was like I've never done an audition before.
Especially in Japan.
I've never done any sort of audition like this.
I've never done.
An audition in Japan.
I've never auditioned for an idol group.
So I was like super duper nervous.
Acapella yes acapella.
And um.
So I was just like okay.
Unfortunately.
I could not follow what the other girls did.
Because they called me first.
And I was like.
Okay.
And so.
I stand up and I'm standing in the middle of the room.
And they ask me some questions.
And they were just like.
They asked me about like dancing.
And singing.
And just you know why I wanted to join backstage.
And I was like this and this and this.
And that and that and that.
And then they were like okay.
Now sing something for us.
And I was like.
Um.
Anything?
Sorry I'm cringing right now.
I'm cringing right now so bad.
I don't know how I got in.
Because they were like.
Yeah anything.
And I was like okay.
Okay.
I don't even.
I just go.
And they were like thank you.
You can sit down now.
And then.
I'm like sitting there.
Like okay.
That's not right.
And then the next girl goes up.
And they ask her like similar questions.
And then they're like okay sing something for us.
And she has a whole dance.
And song prepared.
And she's just like singing the song.
The actual.
She's actually singing.
She's actually singing a song with words.
And.
And a melody.
And like doing a dance to go along with it.
And I was like.
In that moment.
I felt everything drain from my face.
And I was like.
I was like oh.
That's what they meant.
I don't know why.
At the moment.
I thought that they just wanted to hear a little bit of my.
You actually sang Hamtaro didn't you?
That would have been probably better.
Than what I did.
I just sat there.
I was like I messed up.
I messed up.
And then when I got the email that was like.
We got you in.
I was like what?
How?
How did I pass?
Part of me.
A little bit regrets not joining.
Because it probably would have been.
A good experience.
To join.
But like I said.
I wanted to focus on my studies.
And another part was I was so nervous.
I had no confidence in my Japanese.
Like that.
I thought oh my gosh.
I'm going to get yelled at every day at work.
Because they are going to say.
They are going to be like.
Why didn't you understand?
And I would be like.
But it's okay.
It was still good.
It was still an interesting experience.
Being able to.
Being evil.
Being able to even.
Attempt an audition.
For an idol group.
Well it wasn't an idol group.
An idol cafe.
Being evil.
Anyway.
This is an Akiba tour everybody.
So sorry about that little tangent.
We have a figure shop here.
There is so many.
If I point out every figure shop.
In Akiba.
We will be here forever.
Let's go down here a little bit.
This is the.
You can't see it.
This is the other at home cafe.
It's all.
It's all these floors.
All of these floors are at home cafe.
So it's kind of cool.
There is a gamer lounge.
Down here.
You have yellow submarine.
Which is just like a hobby shop.
You have trading cards.
You have the AmiAmi store here as well.
Gamers only.
They have.
They sell.
It's like a.
What's the word?
They have like monitors.
Gaming monitors and stuff like that.
Checking my feed at how cute she is.
You cannot stop me.
What do you mean?
Why?
What do you mean by that?
I'll be honest.
I've never had a reason to go into this building.
There's like a.
One of those other tourist spots here.
Like those tourist stores.
They sell a bunch of luggage.
That's all I know.
But I've never had a reason to go into this building.
So I don't actually really know what's all in it.
Isn't it?
Looks like just trading cards.
So.
Yeah.
Let's see.
So here.
Just to get you guys caught up to speed.
This is Chuo-dori.
This is the main road.
If we go back here a little bit.
There's.
Actually this is the other Gigo.
There's another Gigo down there.
This one is the Gigo that does.
That has the cafe in it.
Wait.
Is it this one?
Is it Sango?
Sango?
Or is it the one down there?
I think it's this one.
I'm pretty sure it's this one.
Is the one that has the cafe in it.
As well.
Yeah.
Collab Cafe.
So.
Usually though these require a reservation.
At least they used to in the past.
I haven't been to one in a long time.
But it's an arcade.
And also.
Last time I was here.
There was a Vispo.
A little collab cafe and stuff.
Mulan.
Mulan is just another.
I'd say touristy store.
But it's really just like.
Used figures and things like that.
You have a Yoshinoya.
Which is.
Gyudon.
You have a Gogo Kare.
There's nothing really.
Over here.
I'm gonna go back down.
This way though.
So here's the Kotobukiya.
Oh yeah.
Esports Lounge.
It says it right there.
There you go.
Esports Lounge.
I wish it was open though.
I wish you could see inside.
Oh wait.
Maybe from here.
Just kidding.
Here.
If I'm going too fast.
Just let me know.
If you're like.
Mint I can't see.
Why?
Always someone.
It looks cool though.
It looks cool in there.
I've always wanted to go to this place.
Because it's like a ghost.
A ghost themed.
Like a Chinese ghost themed.
Cafe.
Maybe I'll go next time.
Sometimes I'm worried because.
Sometimes they're less cafe and more bar like.
And those two places.
One.
Tend to be more expensive.
And two.
I don't really drink.
So I'm just kind of like.
What will I get?
Jiangshi.
Yeah you have like these billboards.
That are all like different types of cafes.
So you have this one.
Which this one I've always.
I'm going to go to this one next time.
Because hold on.
Sorry I'm skipping ahead a little bit.
Wait hold on.
Can you see it from here?
Yeah it's all like all this foresty.
Everything up here.
It's all these.
It's like this foresty.
Like it looks.
So cool in there.
Witch's garden.
But you can see here.
It's 800 yen.
Sorry for the giant arrow.
It's 800 yen for 30 minutes.
Oh wait.
Oh wait that's soft drink.
That's soft drink all you can drink.
All you can drink soft drink.
I can't see the.
There's a course here.
I thought that was the table charge.
Oh maybe not.
But 800 yen for 30 minutes.
How much are you drinking?
How much even soft drinks.
I don't think I can get through.
Even like 3 soft drinks in 30 minutes.
You know.
That's like.
Sucking it down.
I know right.
I don't think I can get through so much.
Soft drinks wouldn't be worth it.
But for the alcohol it's 1500 yen for 30 minutes.
I wonder what the table charge is here.
Hmm.
There's another maid cafe.
This is kind of a maid cafe building.
I'm so sad because this Lawson used to be.
Um.
It used to be.
A dragon quest themed Lawson.
And when you go inside.
It would go.
And when you left it would go.
Or it would play another sound.
And they played like the dragon quest.
Theme inside and everything.
But I found.
I don't know if it's permanent.
But I found another dragon quest themed Lawson.
In Shibuya.
Just my last trip.
And I was like.
Oh my gosh.
Did it move here?
I had never seen it before.
I don't know if it was there before.
They still have one in Shibuya.
Yeah right.
Was it there before?
Anyway okay.
I got a little ahead of myself.
Let's head back.
Giving a tour is hard.
Because there's so much.
There's so many roads.
So this is where.
The chubby girl cafe used to be.
It was this building.
I believe.
This is where the chubby girl cafe used to be.
Ah!
You can see it!
Shangri-La.
Yes.
But it is not here anymore.
So if you put in Shangri-La.
Into Google Maps.
It might take you here.
It is not here anymore.
So do not come over here.
I will show you where the new location is.
I'll show you where the new location is.
It still exists.
Stop saying no!
It's just not in this location.
It moved.
But yeah.
Let's see.
Down here.
Made cafes.
As you can see.
There's a whole building of them.
Made cafes everywhere.
Akihabara is so perfect!
There's a Coco's restaurant down here.
Which is just a.
Just a family restaurant.
But they have.
They have quesadillas.
And here.
If you see the hello storage.
That means you've reached.
Akiba Zettai Ryouiki!
Which is one of my favorite.
Made cafes.
It's super duper cute.
The girls are very cute.
The performances are always so good.
So I recommend.
Zettai Ryouiki.
Very much.
I love their uniforms.
Me too!
There's also more stuff down this street.
But we'll go down here later.
We'll go down here later.
So many maids.
I know.
Actually here.
This place.
Is a Warhammer store.
Which I was.
So shocked to see.
When I saw it.
I was like.
I messaged Matara immediately.
Matara!
There's a Warhammer store in Akiba!
She was like.
Yeah I know.
I was like.
You knew?
You knew something about Akiba that I didn't?
But it's right next to Akiba Culture Zone.
So...
Matara knows more about Akiba.
Than me!
Yeah but...
Yeah.
I've never been in.
Because I don't know anything about Warhammer.
It also says it's a cafe.
I'm more curious about the cafe.
Than anything.
Let's see.
Which way do we...
Let's go down the main street.
A little bit.
And then I'll show you more of the backstreet stuff.
Backstreet stuff.
Alright!
Look at all these people.
This building here.
Sometimes they do events.
Down here.
Like...
Like game festivals.
Or really anything.
I've seen concerts there.
I've seen figures there.
I've seen like Tamashii Nation stuff.
Stuff stuff there.
Um...
Yeah.
Lots of stuff there.
That you can see sometimes.
There's a big camera here.
Oh yeah!
There's also McDonald's.
I showed you the other McDonald's by Yodobashi Camera.
It was the one...
It's over there.
This one's also...
McDonald's.
Hello!
Hello.
Um...
This is the...
When you're lost, by the way.
The train station is right here.
This is the UDX building that I showed before.
It has some...
Some...
Sometimes they do like events and promo things here as well.
Like uh...
I saw a big...
Big pop-up for the new Idol Master.
The school...
The school Idol Master.
But um...
Down here, there's Tamashii Nation.
There's the train station.
We honestly haven't gotten that far at all.
There's so much to see in Akihabara.
We barely walked like two feet away from the...
From the...
From the station.
Yeah.
Let's go back to the main road.
Pew!
You'll see a lot of people like taking pictures of like this...
Section.
Of...
Of Akihabara.
It's kind of like iconic for the at-home poster.
And then this...
Whatever place...
The pawn shop.
That I'm always like...
It always feels so out of place every time I see it.
Um...
And then there's always like a bunch of anime and game signs.
It's very...
This scene is so Akihabara.
You know?
Yeah!
It always reminds me of Dragon Ball 2.
Every time I see it.
So yeah.
Big camera here.
Which has lots of great stuff.
Big camera is not just Akihabara.
You can go anywhere.
Um...
So this is where the new Volks building is.
The one that I showed earlier.
That turned into a sad, sad drug store.
It is now here.
This is where Toranoano was.
So it's kind of sad.
But at least it turned into Volks.
Um...
So you have your Dolphy stuff.
You have a...
You have a bunch of hobby stuff in there.
Um...
Like figures...
Just general merch and everything.
Um...
You have a Taito here.
Which...
Do they show it in this picture?
Oh...
Oh my gosh.
It's Taito...
Wait.
September.
It's Taito pre...
Okay.
B...
It's Taito...
What do you even call those?
It's Taito's BC.
Before the Clappening.
So there's these...
Oh I don't want to say it.
They're so annoying.
There's these stupid...
These stupid fucking things that they put out.
There's like three of them.
Oh my god.
They're so annoying.
They look like birds.
The little clappers.
I hate them.
They're so annoying.
They're so...
They sit there and they go...
All day long.
And there's...
Why are there three?
But there's three of them.
And they just sit there and they're just like...
And it's so...
So annoying.
I hate...
I hate walking past it every time.
I'm like Taito what are you...
Why did you put those out?
They're so annoying.
I think they talk.
I just don't know what they're saying.
Because I try to...
I try to just...
Tune them out.
They're so...
They're like...
They're like... I don't even know.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can find a picture.
Taito...
Arcade... Taito Station...
Akihabara.
I don't even know what to call them though.
Like I have to find a really recent picture.
Because...
They are recent.
They...
And they like sit on top of the arcade machines.
They... Let me... Actually I can draw a picture of them.
That might be easier.
I'm gonna draw a picture real quick.
One second.
Uh...
Woah what the hell?
There we go.
So they look like...
Uh...
They look... They are...
Oh no.
Oops my bad.
This one.
They have like...
This bulbous head.
And this tiny tube body.
And they like...
Have their little feet down here.
They look like they could be from Petscop.
And then they have eyes.
Like beady... Little stupid beady eyes.
And then they have this...
Dumbass duck beak looking shit.
And then they have arms that do this.
They go over their head.
And they have giant...
Clapping hands.
And they're...
They're bright red.
Like that.
And all they do...
They talk.
They open their mouths.
And they go like...
And then just...
And they clap their hands.
But there's three of them.
And they don't shut up.
Thank you.
Hey, what's wrong with duck beaks?
Oh.
Sorry, ducky.
They even look annoying.
I know.
I want to punch them every time.
And they're super loud.
They are.
They're so loud.
I just...
I'm so...
I know one day they'll probably...
Grow on me.
One day...
One day I'll like go back to Akiba.
And they'll be gone.
And I'll be like...
Where's the clappy ducks?
And I'll be so sad.
I'll be like... I'll be like walking by...
The Taito Arcade.
And I'll be like...
Oh, it's so quiet.
And I'll look to the top of the arcade machine...
With wistful eyes.
And I'll just imagine them up there...
Greeting me.
And I'll just be so sad.
I'll be like...
Little clappy man.
Where did you go?
My eyes will glaze over with tears.
They'll just...
They'll be...
I'll do like a sad nod being like...
Yeah.
Yeah, I hope you're out there clapping in heaven.
Mima!
So annoying.
The fact that I could draw it...
Probably as accurate as I could...
From memory...
Just probably goes to...
Uh oh.
Probably goes to show...
How much of an impact they've made on my afterlife.
Truly.
God.
Anyway.
I could listen to you...
Talk about Akiba forever.
You're my favorite geography teacher.
Thank you, student K-Barn.
They're called Big Clappy.
Wait, actually?
Big Clappy.
Oh my god, you're...
No!
Oh my god, no way!
Oh my god.
I already closed out of my picture.
No.
No!
I
already closed out of my picture.
But please, look...
Okay, I'm gonna get a picture.
I'm going to show you guys a picture to show how accurate...
My paint...
MS Paint picture was.
Okay, are you guys ready for this?
Are you guys ready to see how accurate this was?
There's no way!
It was exactly spot on!
Not a single detail off!
I have to buy one now.
I have to buy one.
The Big Crappy.
Oh my gosh, I just realized I don't have my noise gate on.
Big Crappy.
Meet my...
I can't.
I can't!
Seeing that just ruined my day.
Talented, brilliant, incredible...
Stop!
Stop Lady Gaga!
Sorry, I accidentally...
I accidentally just opened a Lady Gaga video.
I have...
saved it on my computer.
Oh gosh, sorry.
That was probably so loud.
My tummy hurts.
Imagine a horror game where you're chased by these things.
You would hear it forever.
Forever ago.
You would hear it across the world.
It's clapping so hard.
It doesn't sound like heaven is their final destination.
Ugh, okay.
Okay, back to the tour.
We're doing a tour again, everybody.
Anyways, there's a Taito station there.
Again, it's just another...
Another... what's the word?
Arcade.
This building, I believe, is finished.
Is it not?
Am I making that up?
Maybe...
Wait.
Or I'm thinking of another one.
No.
No, I think this building is finished now.
Yeah, it was finished, right?
Yeah, I remember because...
I went there for a...
Tomie.
They did a Tomie collab.
In one of the stores.
It was like a pop-up stop.
So...
It was...
I ended up not getting anything.
I was so sad.
I forgot to go back and get some stuff.
But...
Yeah.
Yes.
It's now...
Well, the anime is here.
The anime, I'm pretty sure, is still here.
I think it's just like a bunch of random stores.
If I remember correctly, there's a cell phone store at the bottom.
And then it's like random stuff.
And I think there's like a card shop in there as well.
I don't quite remember exactly.
All that's in there.
But there's the anime here.
Ta-da!
It's like these two buildings.
There are...
If you go into this anime, this store has its own elevator and this store has its own elevator.
And they do not connect.
So, make sure you go in both.
They both have their own different staircases.
I believe this one on the top floor has This one... I think this one...
Is it this one that has the cafe or this one?
Yeah, it's pretty inconvenient.
Not gonna lie.
But this one, I think, has the event stuff at the top floor here.
But the top floor of this one has the Yo!
Star section and blue archive and stuff.
So...
But one of them also has a cafe.
A small little cafe.
I say cafe, it's more like snacks and drinks and stuff.
I was disappointed in the anime cafe.
Yeah, it's not really a cafe.
It's like I said, it's like snacks and drinks.
Los Timbos!
Thank you for the five!
Gifted thank you!
But yeah, so just be careful.
I'm just like, oh, but I already went up all the floors.
But did you go up this one as well?
I think this store, this one on the right also has more stuff for those interested in the BL variety.
And this one is of others.
Let's see.
For those wondering!
Bao Bao!
Yes, this is the miso dough!
This is the famous Bao Bao Mr. Doughnut!
So you can go here and you can sit up there and eat your doughnuts.
And um...
Yeah!
It's a great view because you get to see you know, so much of Akiba.
I mean like the iconic stuff you can see.
Don Quixote you can see.
Well, I don't want to sit there anymore because there's demons afoot.
Or should I say, a clap.
But yeah, um...
There's a soft map here.
They have games.
They have used electronic stuff like that.
But yeah, miso dough!
Always go to miso dough.
Get the pandering!
I don't remember what's here.
This is not where they're building the other Appa.
That's more down there.
So I don't remember what's here.
To be honest.
I don't remember.
Another Namtara.
You have a pachinko parlor here.
And then Don Quixote as I mentioned before.
Hold on, let's go down a little bit.
So this Don Quixote is open 24-7.
It has Arcade.
6th and 7th floor.
What floor is...
Is it the 5th floor?
The 4th or 5th floor has the At Home.
But there also is the AKB48 theater there as well.
Don Don Don Don Quixote!
Don Quixote!
Don Quixote is like a general store.
Yes, it is.
You can get clothes.
You can get You can get snacks.
You can get makeup.
You can get skin care.
You can get costumes.
This particular Don Quixote has a really cute Sanrio section that I like to go check out.
This is Japanese Walmart.
Basically.
Yeah.
I didn't want to say it but yeah.
Basically.
But it's also this Don Quixote in particular I mean any Don Quixote that you go to in like a major city.
Shibuya.
Shinjuku.
Akihabara.
You know like the big tourist hot spots.
The Don Quixotes are going to be sooo crowded.
And again, Japan loves to pack so much in a tiny space.
So the aisles are very small.
There's tons of people.
It is very very very very jam packed in there.
So just be aware about that.
But at the bottom here they have they have a crepe place.
They have a takoyaki place.
I don't remember what the other one is.
It's a great gift spot though.
It is!
Yes!
You can get so much at Don Quixote.
It's crazy.
Yeah yeah.
And yeah great place to get pen lights.
You can!
You can get pen lights here.
They have lots of.
You can get UO's here.
I love.
Don't get me wrong.
I love Don Quixote.
I love Don Quixote so much.
I buy stuff from there all the time.
Oh yeah!
There's a Tsukumo.
Ah yeah.
You have traders here.
Another place.
Buy game.
Uh...
Buy...
Um...
They have everything here basically.
So much stuff here.
Yeah yeah.
Here we go.
Game.
Blu-ray DVD.
Hobby figurine.
Audio iPhone.
Traders is a great place to go too.
Yes yes.
What is here?
I don't remember.
Unless it wasn't done.
Sorry.
I should like...
I should do like...
In the past I've made videos of me just walking through Akiba.
Like not talking.
Just like walking down the street.
I never posted them anywhere though.
I just always kept them for myself.
So...
I mean I intended on posting them.
I just never did.
So...
Um... Let's see.
What's some other things that I can think of?
My brain is starting to lose it.
Mother made dream in here.
There's Tsurugaya here.
At least one of them.
There's one Tsurugaya here.
There's several in Akihabara.
As well.
Um...
You can't see it but there's the Akiba all here.
There's like just small...
What's it called?
Like figure shops and electrics...
Electronic stores and stuff.
As you can see.
Um...
There's Carl's Jr.
There's Carl's Jr. Um...
Okay so there's a mocha cat cafe here.
I have heard from friends about mocha cat cafe to maybe don't go.
Even though it's a chain.
But apparently from what my friends have told me they had an incident where they knew that their cats were sick and they just let them continue being sick.
So...
Um...
I don't know how true that is but I... you know...
But...
But it's what my friends said.
I hope it's not true.
But it has made me weary of going to mocha now.
To this chain.
And there's mochas in like...
There's one in Harajuku.
There's one in Shinjuku.
It's a really popular cat cafe chain.
So...
There is a cat cafe though in Akiba that I really like.
So I will take you guys to that one.
Um...
I've never been to this meat place.
Maybe Matara would like it.
Because it's meat and wine.
Um...
There's also some other stuff like...
Oh wait...
There's also like an idol...
Um...
Is this where the Ophelia Saga is?
I think so.
I think this is where the Ophelia is.
And some other like idol...
Um...
What's the words?
Idol cafes?
Yeah.
Meat wine.
Idol Carl's Jr. Exactly!
Exactly!
If you need the most inexpensive family restaurant in the entire world.
Saizeria is your man.
Saizeria is an Italian family restaurant.
And it is the most inexpensive restaurant you can probably ever go to ever.
It is so...
It is so cheap.
It's actually so cheap.
If you want...
If you were just going to Japan on a budget.
Saizeria is vaguely Italian.
Is the best way to put it.
Yes!
Vaguely Italian.
Oh!
Um...
Remember how I mentioned that Nikumansei opened up a new shop.
It's in here.
So uh...
I haven't checked it out yet.
I will go next time I'm in Japan.
Olive Garden too.
But seriously!
The only thing is because it's so inexpensive and they're open late.
It's very crowded.
There's usually like a line.
So um... Especially if there's an event.
Um...
I like Getsu.
This is a uh...
This is an eroge store.
That I somewhat frequent.
So um...
If I'm brave enough.
Sometimes I'm a little shy and I don't go in.
But uh...
Um...
So...
If you're looking for eroge...
Um...
I like to go there.
Anyways.
We're just gonna gloss over that.
There's another Akibao.
Another Akibao.
Oh you can see it better here.
Yeah!
No that's main dream.
Where?
Maybe it's in here.
Oh!
No just kidding.
That's a dentist.
There's another Tsurugaya.
There's just so much.
Um...
Let's keep going.
You know what?
Let's just keep going down the main road until we get to...
Until we get to the end of...
Like the main...
Main main stuff.
And uh...
Then I'll take you down some of the back roads that we didn't go down before.
Or that I like avoided.
Not avoided.
But you know what I mean.
Um...
Royal Host is another chain um...
Family restaurant.
It's more expensive but the food is actually so good.
It's actually so good.
If I ever go to Japan...
I'm coming out with like $200 of eroge.
The great thing is too...
Is that you can find so much cheap eroge.
So $200 would be like...
A ton of stuff.
It would be so great.
Obsessed with Royal Host.
Yeah there's also this Tendon place.
Which is pretty good.
Oh wait!
Uh...
The Pepper Lunch is down here.
I'll take you there.
Obviously.
This...
This is I'm pretty sure going to be the Appa.
Does it say?
It doesn't say yet.
But I'm almost positive.
This is going to be a new Appa Hotel.
Which is like...
That makes it like...
Five in Akiba.
It's kind of crazy.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you.
Another one?
I know right?
Another one.
It's kind of crazy.
Um...
I like this Ramen here.
The Tonkotsu Ramen here is pretty good.
I think this is also a chain though.
So it's not just Akiba.
But I like their stuff.
There's a um...
There's some more maid cafes in here.
I'm pretty sure this is also where the um...
Lillian Plyan moved to.
Which I like them.
They have two locations.
Is it here?
It might be.
I think they did move in here.
Um...
Uh...
They're like a cute fairy themed.
Um...
Maid cafe.
Very cute.
Uh...
There's like a cool figure store here.
Let's see.
Jambara!
More electronic stuff here.
Fairy themed?
Yeah!
I call this place maid cafe building.
Because it's all maid cafes.
Except Yakiniku-like.
At the very bottom.
Uh... Heart of Hearts used to be up here.
But actually now it's in um...
That location where I showed with the witch's garden.
It actually reopened.
After a little bit of...
What seems to be kind of drama.
Um... But there's several maid cafes in here.
To get into this... into the maid cafes though.
You have to go down here.
Chup, chup, chup, chup, chup.
And you go down here.
Chup, chup, chup, chup.
And you enter...
You enter...
You enter here.
So if you see...
If you're just like, mind escape.
That sounds like a cool cafe to go to.
You can't get into it on the other way.
It looks shady.
Yeah, a little bit.
But that's just how it is.
That's just how it is, baby.
Los Tembos!
Thank you for that 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Yeah, there's some maid cafes in here as well.
But I have not been...
Oh my gosh, please.
Please!
It's just enough every time.
I have not been to these ones because...
I'm not gonna lie.
They kinda look a little shady as well.
So...
Um...
Let's see.
So Royal House...
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
Let's go back to the main road.
We're in June 2021.
No, let's do...
July 2022.
As recent as we can get.
King and Queen was a good stop for a drink.
I've never been...
There used to be a place called The Alley.
Which, um...
Which, uh...
What's the word?
They had bubble tea.
Or was it The Alley?
I think so.
But they had bubble tea.
Which I would go there a couple times.
Um...
Let's see...
So, one of my favorite places to eat...
in Akihabara...
is actually right here.
This Moss Burger.
Kind of similar to...
Fuhomoko.
It has it, like, you know, with the Mr. Donuts.
How they like to just eat up top with their Pondering.
I like to come here and I like to get the...
Yakiniku Rice Bun Burger.
And I sit up here and I just kind of like to...
look at Akihabara.
Um...
It's not as nice as the...
as the Mr. Donuts, but...
Um...
But it's still something that I do...
basically every time I'm in Akihabara.
Is I go here and I sit at the...
I sit at the...
Oh, hi people!
I sit at the little table and I like to...
Um...
eat the Rice Bun Burger.
Because it's the best thing!
I never order anything else at Moss Burger except the Rice Bun Burger.
It's most delicious ever.
Hmm...
So...
It's so awesome.
I love...
I like that spot a lot.
Um...
Um, a little more down...
It becomes like...
a little bit less.
You get some gacha stores...
and stuff.
Oh, right here...
is like a big, um...
It says... it has like the Miku...
racing right now.
Um...
It's... for a while it's been like...
kind of a Good Smile store?
Not Good Smile...
But it... is it Good Smile?
It has... it has like racing Miku...
and they have like some other figures...
and um...
Uh...
Is Good Smile HQ?
No way!
What?
But it's still here!
It's still here!
It's um... it's just like... they have the...
This looks like it's just a racing Miku...
like pop-up... but they do...
still have racing Miku stuff inside.
They just have other figures as well.
Um... like they have like some...
pop-up parade things and they have...
uh... just like...
just like some general figure stuff.
Mm-mm-mm...
There used to be a...
scam postcard store right around here.
But this one?
This one?
With the lady that always tries to get you to...
go in?
Uh... this chat time is not...
here anymore, which makes me so sad.
It was a bubble tea place.
Ahem.
It's funny because in the game Akiba's Trip, you like fight these ladies.
You fight these ladies because they're always so pushy about getting you to buy the art.
So annoying.
Um... down here is another...
Oh... wait... what... we... okay... 2019.
I was gonna say this is...
I think it's... this building?
Or this building?
One of these buildings is another...
um... made...
Oh!
Made cafe building.
Okay, let's see.
This one.
I was close.
This is another, like, very made cafe.
There's a bunch of different themes here.
Um... one of them is a Vtuber.
I think it's this one.
It's the Vtuber themed cafe.
I still haven't gone because I'm very... someone once said that it was weird.
When they went.
So... I'm still deciding.
Is that Picardine?
That might be Picardine.
But yeah, there's lots of made cafes and themed cafes.
I mean, this one's a cheerleading themed one.
Not necessarily a made cafe.
How weird?
I don't know.
I'm gonna go next time.
I'm gonna get over my fears.
Of the weird cafe.
I won't tell them I'm a Vtuber.
Oh yeah, see?
You can kind of see it's closed off.
But it is, it is, like, open all the time now.
It used to always be, like, from every time I saw it, it was like a Miku...
A Miku...
Miku, like, exhibition type thing.
Great tour!
Have you watched Akiba Made War?
Hi, Sketch!
Thank you!
I'm actually in the middle of watching it.
I watched an episode right before the stream.
I don't remember what episode I'm on, though.
I'm on episode, like, five?
I think?
If you're into Hello Project, there's the big Hello Project store here.
There's also some other hobby stores up in here.
An army store.
This hobby shop that has a bunch of, like, military stuff.
I've only been once.
Um...
Well, yeah!
The quote-unquote main Akiba stuff really kind of ends here.
But also not!
There's also a bunch of... See?
Chuo-dori Avenue.
So Chuo-dori is this main street here.
Um...
There's some other stuff I want to show.
Some, like, little things, like, off the beaten path.
Um, if you come down this way...
I always use Tam Tam as, like, my marker.
It's like my...
It's my big marker here.
Let's see...
Um...
This way.
Oh, here.
So this is a...
This is a cafe called...
Fruits de saison?
I think?
Does it say?
Furu Fudu Saison is what's covered up.
Furu Fudu Saison And basically...
It's the most delicious...
It's so...
Awesome!
They're so delicious.
They are, um...
So, as the title implies...
The fruits change each season.
So...
They, uh...
They, um...
Only have whatever fruit is in...
Oh!
Oh, we're back!
Hello?
Just refresh.
They got her.
We're back?
Okay, sorry.
Sorry about that.
So this is Furu Fudu Saison.
And like I said...
As the title implies...
They...
They serve parfaits...
Based on what fruit is in season.
So, um...
So you'll only get stuff that is...
Of that season.
And like the menu is very...
It changes all the time.
It's so good.
I don't know why it's called Fruf.
But it says Fruits Parfait.
Or does that say...
That's...
I don't know.
But I highly recommend this place.
It's really, really delicious.
It's so good.
Fruf du Saison.
But also here...
Is a place that I love to go to...
All the time.
Oh my god!
Shiratama Sensei!
It's called Blend Dream Candy.
And if you love...
Blend Dream Park...
If you like doujin artists...
I love their apple pie.
Yeah!
I'll have to try it...
Next time!
If you like...
Doujin artists and stuff...
This is a store of just...
Like gachapon...
And tapestries...
And...
It's mostly gachapon, I'll be honest.
But they have like vending machines of art...
Of like tapestries...
And various goods of different artists...
Like Shiratama Sensei...
And Pan no Mimi...
And...
Kantoku...
Hmmm...
Very adorable, very humorous...
Humorous?
What's so funny?
But...
Yeah!
I like this place.
I like to come here and get their gachapon.
But if you're wondering...
Where is this?
This is like the most random side street ever.
If you go down this street all the way...
Which I'm gonna show you...
Which actually...
It's kinda fun.
Right here is the fire department.
You can see their own little anime mascot.
The fire department has their own anime mascot.
Sorry, I'm skipping a bunch of places.
But...
Trying to show as much as possible.
Look at that!
We're back at the station!
There's Tamashii Nations.
There's the station.
There's UDX.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah!
So it's just a little bit of a walk from there.
Damn dragon!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Yeah, we went in a full circle!
I'm actually gonna go back down this way too.
Because there's something else I wanted to show.
More, more, more.
Did you know you can walk inside M's on Google Maps?
Wait, I tried!
I tried!
How do you do it?
What do you do?
Fellow kids.
Cute.
Oh my gosh, Ami!
Thank you for the raid, Ami!
Thank you!
Froggers!
Hello everybody!
I'm doing a tour of Akihabara.
My favorite place ever.
I've kind of shown a lot of stuff already.
But...
But uh...
Um...
Yeah, welcome!
David!
Thank you for the gifted!
Murphy, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Raymac, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys!
Tenhausen, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Spank, thank you for the 20!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Ducky, thank you for the gifted!
Thank you guys!
Let me see...
I actually am so curious if this is here.
I'm so curious.
Well, first off...
Actually, where...
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna be checking sideways every so often.
It's that!
Wait, can I go in there?
This!
If you guys follow Ayami-sensei, This is where she had her collaboration cafe with Asan Cafe.
So it was here.
But it's this!
No!
Wait!
You can see him!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Do you guys want to see the scariest thing?
Hold on, I have to...
I have to send it to...
Oops, that's TikTok.
Don't listen.
I have to send it to myself.
You can see his reflection!
Okay, so imagine...
Hold on, I have to find the picture.
Actually, imagine you're walking down the street at night in Akihabara.
Actually, I walk this way because...
I walk this way!
No.
I walk this way because I...
I had some friends that were staying down the street.
And so I was going to meet them.
And it was dark.
It was night time.
It was, you know...
I don't want to say it was quite late.
But it was, you know...
The sun had set.
Where is this picture?
Can you guys tell what it is from the reflection?
And this is from July of 2022.
So, um...
I just want to let you know that.
Where is this picture?
Hold on, I'm going to find it.
I'm so sorry.
I should have had this prepared.
But I actually didn't even know if he was going to be there.
Mothra?
A clown?
Close.
Maybe.
A bird man.
Flamingo.
Why flamingo?
Where is this picture?
Oh, wait.
I think I'm close.
Oh!
I found it!
I found it.
Okay.
Let me pull it up.
Uh, wait.
Wait.
Uh, one second.
Sorry.
Um...
One second.
I didn't want to accidentally open the pictures in the wrong browser.
Which is why I hid it.
Sorry.
One second.
Uh, and also let me check for reflection.
So...
You're walking down the street.
And you see him.
Oh.
It's dark and you lost your way.
You don't know where you're going.
But you hear a rustle behind...
In a dark alleyway.
You turn, confused.
And who else could it be?
Actual cannibal...
Olaf from Frozen.
Do you see it now?
With the reflection and then the picture?
This is what I saw walking home at night.
It scared the actual crap out of me.
I was like, oh my god!
I don't know why he's there.
Actual cannibal.
Olaf from Frozen.
Is real.
And he exists in this building.
Yorozuya 7 Biru.
Across from Asan Cafe.
And clearly, this is from July 22.
Uh, 2020...
2022.
So...
Scary.
It's scary, right?
Um, so...
Woah.
My phone just fell.
Sorry.
Um, so he's been there for several years now.
Um, so you can probably go to this place and visit scary Olaf.
Again, he's across from Cafe Asan.
This is a real mystery.
Have you seen it?
Bajamin.
That Olaf.
Why... why am I here?
Why am I here?
Why?
Isn't it too scary?
Why am I here?
Olaf is scary scary.
Anyway, I just wanted to share the Blendream and the Cafe Asan.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Let me out!
I have it.
I have it since last year.
Since last year?
Since 2022.
This is June!
And he's holding like a...
He's holding a...
Oh my gosh.
I think I...
Oh, there we go.
He's holding a candy bucket.
Like a Halloween bucket.
So, I thought he was like a Halloween...
Like prop?
But, no.
I don't know.
That Olaf is so terrifying.
It's so scary.
It's so funny to see.
Oh, I like this hotel here.
This hotel...
Oh, here.
You can see the name.
The Dormy Inn Akihabara.
I really like because at the top, right up here, is...
is an onsen.
It's an outdoor onsen.
It's not very big.
But it's Dormy Inn Goated.
Yeah!
It's really nice.
So, it's also...
The rooms are like kind of more Japanese style.
Like they have the tatami mats and everything like that.
But...
Dormy Inn rocks.
Yeah!
Um...
But...
And it's quite affordable.
I think it still counts as a...
As a business hotel.
So, it's quite affordable.
And...
You can use the onsen for free.
Do you like the Idol Master Mint?
Yeah, I do!
Didn't know there was an onsen in Akihabara.
It's like...
Onsen maybe in quotes.
But it's still really nice.
I stayed at the Dormy Inn across from Tokyo Dome last month.
It was amazing.
Oh, nice!
Yes, also I should mention it is a chain.
So...
It's not like you have to stay only at this one.
There are Dormy Inns at other places.
And I believe they all have the onsen at the top.
So it's pretty nice.
Um...
Also, if you didn't realize, we're back to...
Chuo-dori.
But you might also notice...
There is a...
Train station here.
This is for the metro.
Which um...
You saw...
There was the metro for Akihabara station.
Oh, there's Pepper Lunch!
But the metro for Akihabara station is the Hibiya Line.
This is actually um...
Hold on, I'm trying to get the name so you can see it.
Uh...
What is this?
I'm not sure yet.
There we go.
Sui...
Suihirocho.
So...
If you are coming to Akihabara...
And you're just like...
Ah, my hotel is not...
Is not...
It does not go directly to Akihabara.
You could also check to see...
If it goes to Suihirocho.
Because...
Um...
This will also lead you...
Exactly on Chuo-dori.
On the main street.
So it's not um...
It's not like Akiba station proper.
But it is still in the heart of Akihabara.
And then there's, you know, the exit here.
Or exit entrance here.
Exit entrance over there.
Yes, the Ginza Line.
You can see...
You can see it's the orange one right there.
Um, there is...
There are a couple other train stations you can take.
Um...
What was one?
Hold on, let me check.
I can't remember the name.
Um...
Hold on, I'm gonna check from maps.
There's another one that takes you...
It's a little bit more of a walk.
But by a walk, I mean like 2 minutes.
It's not even that long.
Um...
Mmm...
Directions...
To Akihabara...
Directions to Akihabara...
The other station is...
Wait, here we go.
Train station.
Is, um...
Ogawa-machi.
Oh, there is also Okachimachi, yeah.
But Ogawa-machi takes you...
Um...
Takes you...
It's like...
I would have to go kind of far.
It's kind of all the way...
To Akihabara station.
But it drops you off like...
Like maybe like a 3 minute walk...
To...
Um...
To like Pasela area.
So...
If you're like trying to get to Akihabara...
I would definitely look at some stations...
Around as well because...
Not all of them are going to lead to...
Akihabara station proper.
But you could maybe find...
I mean Google maps will do that for you, right?
Like...
Google maps will find you the best way to get there but...
Um...
You know, you don't have to go to...
Whoa!
Where are we here?
You don't have to go to Akihabara station proper.
There's a couple others around too.
Wow, Japan has CBD.
I know, right?
It's so weird to see now.
It's really weird to see.
I'm trying to get in here.
So...
If we're going to go down some of the back streets...
Now...
There's culture zone.
So...
Akihabara seems huge and small...
All at the same time.
It's so big and small...
Where?
Dolphin.
I can't tell.
Where am I?
I know where I am but like...
I'm trying to figure out...
Okay, hold on.
For some reason...
I always...
If I'm looking this way...
It's more confusing than if I'm looking this way.
I don't know why.
Bunny Garden!
Yes!
Okay.
This is...
Yes!
Okay, that's why I kept turning around.
This is the Bunny Garden Street!
Right here!
This is the Bunny Garden Street.
Right here.
And so...
Not here.
This...
This is where the Chubby Girl Made Cafe is.
Homemade Cafe and Dining...
Honey, honey...
I've never been here before but...
This is where it's at.
In case you are...
Trying to find it.
Changri Da is here.
You're welcome.
Everybody who's been like...
Where is it?
Yeah.
I was like...
I know it's here.
I thought it was either this street or this one street over.
But I was like...
No, I'm pretty sure it's this one.
Of course, there's the Hard Off and the Hobby Off.
There's some kebabs.
There's kebabs!
There's always the Star Kebab which is like...
The more popular one.
Which they closed down for a while.
And then they opened back up.
Which is right...
Oh!
I mentioned...
Wait.
No, it's the other street.
Oh, there it is.
No, that's not Star Kebab.
Where is Star Kebab?
Where the hell am I?
Oh, that's the park.
It's this way.
Sorry guys, I'm starting to get sleepy.
There's Star Kebab.
A culture zone is way farther than it looks.
But you can always see it.
It looks so far, but it's like a good landmark.
You know what I mean?
This is where...
This is another place that I...
The other Jambara...
Another retro...
Retro game place down here.
In the basement.
Someone asked.
Other than like Super Potato.
Sorry.
There's here as well.
Yes, yes, yes.
Star Kebab.
But I know this street.
I know this street the bestest.
And I'll show you why in like two seconds.
Because this place I go...
This street I visit all the time.
Here is Akihabara Deer Stage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did Mint mention Atoreya Akiba Station?
I did, I did.
Here is Akihabara Deer Stage.
My beloved deer stage.
I come to Akihabara.
I go here.
Place.
My lovely deer stage.
You have Arcana Project.
You have Aizawarisa.
You have...
Oh, Mia Regina.
Rest in peace.
Wait, this is from 2022.
Can I see?
Is there a more latest one?
There is not.
That's okay.
They always advertise like recent releases for their talent.
On these little billboards here.
So if you don't know.
Deer Stage.
It is a...
It is a legendary spot of Akihabara.
It is...
Oh yeah, let's go back in time and see.
Oh my gosh, wait.
If I go back to like 2016, it will be Dempa, won't it?
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Wait, I went to March.
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Dempa Gumi Inc.
Welcome to Deer Stage.
And then this is another Dempa Gumi album.
And then this is Moso Calibration.
One Man Live.
Yeah, oh my gosh.
Natsukashii.
It's always been the same.
Thomas, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
So I've talked about it before.
But on the first floor here.
Is like, there's a big stage right here.
You can go in.
If the curtain...
Sometimes the curtain is closed.
Just walk right past it.
You can open up the curtain.
They just do it for like live performances and stuff like that.
If there's gonna be a...
If there's gonna be a live performance.
You just go on in.
As long as it's not a ticketed day, of course.
But they'll stop you of course.
If it is.
And then this floor is the...
Cafe.
And then this floor is the bar.
So the whole building...
Is Deer Stage.
Are they open everyday?
No!
No, they're not.
I don't remember what day they're closed though.
How do you get tickets for Deer Stage?
That's the cool thing.
Unless it's an event.
The tickets might be a little more hard to get.
They're like fan club related and things like that.
But for normal days...
You just walk in and you pay.
And that's it.
It's super easy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder...
2009...
Okay, so...
It's hard to tell.
But this is actually like...
They lift up.
Like they're...
It's like a sliding door basically.
Oh my gosh!
Is that lettuce?
Oh my god, stop!
Are Nora and Petra in this?
I don't think so.
Wait, is Amane in this?
I can't tell.
There's a meeting up front that looks like...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I'm fangirling a little bit.
This is... oh wait.
This would be past...
This would be past Nora and Petra.
I'm pretty sure.
And then...
Muscle calibration again.
Rest in peace.
But yeah, so these lift up actually.
So you can actually see here.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
Oh my gosh, they don't lift it anymore.
Obviously, but...
Wow!
Oh my god.
Old... old...
Dear stage.
Old Akihabara.
But it also still kinda looks the same, doesn't it?
Let's see.
From 2009 to 2022?
This is just a computer store.
Instead of...
What was also a computer store.
So, not so much has changed.
It's gotten a little wider.
It's a blue computer store instead of red.
So, you know, it is kind of... it is a little comforting, right?
Because, you know, so much of Akiba has changed.
But it is really comforting to know that.
Also, so much has stayed the same.
This is Akiba... or Akiba...
This is Dear Stage's official Vocaloid, even, too.
Tone Rion, who is drawn by Poyoyon, one of my favorite artists ever.
Who is also known as Akio Watanabe.
Also known as the Bakemonogatari artist.
Who is also voiced by my Kamioshi Yumemi Nemu!
Yes, he also did the art for Chrisaya!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Isn't Nemu also a Vocaloid?
You are right!
She is also her own Vocaloid!
That she also goes by Yumemi Nemu.
She's very cute.
Yeah.
And they built this family mart a couple years ago.
So, if you are ever at Dear Stage, and you're just like, I'm just here for the live performances.
I don't really want to go to the cafe.
Which, you should go to the cafe.
But, it's only a thousand yen to see the shows.
And you get three a night, usually.
But if you're like, I'm going to go eat.
You can leave.
And then go to family mart.
And then go back.
Yeah.
What else?
There's so much.
I'm going to probably rush a little bit more through some of these.
Because I...
I'm so sleepy.
Oh, whoa!
Yeah, this is all built here.
But I don't remember what it is.
Oh, this ramen place is good.
I'm almost positive I mentioned it before in my previous ones.
But this is a...
This is a chicken ramen.
So, their broth is chicken based.
So, some people can't have pork, right?
So, if you're ever like, I want...
Chicken ramen.
Or I can't have pork.
Then this place has really, really good chicken broth ramen.
But also, if you're just like, I'm vegetarian.
I can't have chicken broth either.
Well, they also have a vegetarian ramen.
So...
So, you can also get full vegetarian ramen at this chicken noodle location.
It's good though.
Yeah, it's good, it's good, it's good.
It's good.
Oh yeah, here...
My friends and I lovingly call this the Deer Stage Appa.
Because it's right next to Deer Stage.
We're just like, go to Deer Stage.
Go to Appa.
Go back home.
So, there's one of the other Appas in Akihabara.
Oh my gosh, I feel like I'm...
There's another Akibao.
I feel like I'm gonna have to do another part.
I feel like I'm...
Living the life.
For those...
Some people mentioned it before.
Here is your Mandarake.
This entire building.
You sell...
You do the selling stuff here at the bottom.
And then every floor above is this whole building is Mandarake.
Not Mandrake.
I mean, yes.
Mandrake.
A part two would be cool.
Maybe if I do a part two, I can do some actual footage that I take.
I will...
Do my best.
I will do my best.
What's your favorite place in the downtown?
The downtown?
Downtown.
When you're slow and you wanna go.
You know you can go.
Downtown.
I like to go to the parlor show.
At the deer stage.
Downtown.
Yeah.
Food recommendations too?
I would actually...
Not gonna lie.
Bashamin has been in the chat.
Bashamin has so many great Akihabara food recommendations.
So, definitely check out her channel.
For...
For her...
Her...
Video tours of Akihabara as well.
And...
I think for me, I probably give more of a perspective from a...
You know, like a tourist.
So...
But she has some really great food recommendations, so...
Hmm...
I'm pitching her.
Yeah, yeah.
She and I have collabed a long time ago in the past, so...
She's always been so cute.
Basamin!
Everybody go follow.
But yeah, here's Mandarake.
Again, you take the stairs.
There's also like a teeny tiny elevator here.
If you don't want to take the stairs like up eight floors.
But the inside is also very tiny and packed so just be mindful.
There's a ramen place here which has really huge ramen.
And they do sometimes collabs with anime shows as well.
Let's see...
Hard off here as well.
I remember this spot very vividly because I was standing like maybe maybe right here or right here.
Also, I love this.
I love how they're just like Hey, check out what maids we've got for at home maid cafe.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you ghost door.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
But I was standing right here.
I remember this spot so vividly because because I was waiting on a friend and this guy came up and he tried talking to me in English.
He was just like Are you lost?
You look so lost.
I was just standing here on my phone like waiting for my friend.
I was like no I'm not lost.
I'm waiting for a friend.
They'll be here soon.
He was just like no.
You are lost.
You are looking at your phone.
You don't know where to go.
I was like no.
No.
I'm just I'm just waiting.
I'm just waiting for my friend.
They'll be here.
They're like I don't believe you.
I don't believe that you're waiting for your friend.
Here.
Come with me.
They tried like They tried kidnapping me.
I had to be like I'm waiting for my friend.
For my friend.
I had to be so insistent.
And then I had to be like oh.
I had to be like my friend is My friend is down here.
So I just walked.
I just It was so weird.
It was such a weird experience.
I was like why are you Why would you think I'm lost?
Looking at my phone.
But then again.
I've also seen some people.
In Akiba.
Some foreigners.
Looking at their phones and I'm like They look lost.
So maybe Maybe they just had a silly look about me.
Here is Tsurugaya.
Another Tsurugaya.
If you're looking for.
Oh.
Kandu.
Is it still here?
It's Kandu.
It's another 100 yen store.
But I prefer 3 coin.
It's part of the Appa.
You are lost is crazy work.
Right?
It's so funny.
There's so many.
Look at this.
I'll be honest.
I buy all my stuff.
From Tsurugaya online.
It sounded like I just said Gaya online.
Tsurugaya Online.
So I don't really visit the stores that much.
Themselves.
Yeah.
Uh.
Wait.
I was like.
Is this the kindergarten?
There's like a random park and kindergarten here.
It's pretty funny.
Trying to look for another place.
It's not Bee Cat though.
Trying to look for the other Annie Song bar that my friend suggested.
Yeah.
Here's the kindergarten.
It's kinda cute because around 5pm.
It is 5pm right?
At 5pm the chimes will go off.
So um.
You can uh.
You'll hear that.
Okay hold on.
I wanna go back.
Not quite done.
Hold on.
I asked my normie friends to pick up an animator book from Mandarake.
While they were in Akiba.
And they were led to the floor with all the doujins.
I mean there are a lot of floors with doujins.
Um this is.
I mentioned it earlier.
Lillian Pleon.
This is the other location.
I think it's this floor and this floor.
But they're very cute.
This floor has like the entrance and uh.
Some other stuff.
I wish these were open.
It's so frustrating.
They're not open.
Um.
There's a restaurant in here.
Pizza I'm pretty sure.
Um.
Okay.
Go back down here.
Oh wait!
Ah!
MADE!
Spotted.
Look how cute they are.
Also in Akiba.
Please don't take pictures.
Of the maids.
Some of them wear signs that like.
Don't take pictures.
But you're not supposed to.
Be respectful.
Don't be those tourists you know.
Because now.
I don't know.
I'm so worried about some places.
Because like you heard about.
How like tourists are banned from certain places.
In.
In Kyoto now.
Because of how they're chasing after them.
The Michael and everything.
The geisha yeah.
Yeah in Gion.
It's kinda crazy.
The that.
The geisha chasers in Gion.
Yeah.
They're banned from like certain streets.
So.
Just be respectful you know.
There's one.
Like one thing to be like.
Yeah.
I'm.
I'm having.
I'm you know.
I'm a foreigner.
I don't really know what I'm doing.
I'm having fun.
I'm trying to be respectful you know.
And there's just being like you know.
Rowdy rude you know.
So.
Down here.
I like this poster.
Because Idol Content Expo.
Is drawn by an idol I really like.
She's in Dempagumi Inc.
Her name is Perorin.
And she drew this.
She's so cute.
Okay.
I think the last time I did my Akiba tour.
We were like Akiba CIA baby.
We're gonna go to Spy Bar Akiba CIA.
I regret to inform you.
That Akiba CIA.
Is no longer.
In fact.
I was gonna say.
I think it's been replaced by a dog thing.
But the dog thing is right here.
But yeah.
Actually it's um.
What is it?
It's another like maid cafe type thing.
I think it's like some.
Moon themed maid cafe.
Or concept cafe.
Whichever.
So there is no more Spy Bar.
Akiba CIA.
The Akiba Chiyoda Intelligence Agency.
I never got to go.
I'll regret it for the rest of my afterlife.
I will.
Now it's Akiba Iris.
Moon themed?
What does that mean?
It's like um.
I think I took a picture of it.
Let me see if I can find it real quick.
Cause I remember taking a picture and being like.
Oh my god no.
Akiba CIA.
Is gone.
I don't know.
When I took a picture of it though.
Any time.
It could have been.
It could have been on my old phone even.
I don't know.
Hold on.
I'll do a brief look over.
Not here.
Is that it?
No that's Umumusume.
I don't want to take too much time though.
Looking for it.
That's a Comiket.
I don't know.
Let me see if maybe we can time travel too.
Nope.
But it's like a different concept cafe now.
So sad.
So so sad.
But what's not sad is if you're looking for.
Thank you.
I have expected to see you on the street view of Dear Sage.
Why?
I don't just stand out there all the time.
Thank you.
Oh wait.
I think I'm reading the wrong one.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tour of Akiba.
It was so cool seeing all the places.
I'm planning on visiting sometime next year.
So I'll be sure to check out your recommendations.
Yeah of course.
Thank you.
If we didn't want to hear you fangirling.
We wouldn't tune in to watch you talk about your holy land.
Yeah.
So this is actually a theater.
A live theater.
So there's twin box garage.
Which to be honest.
I've never been to this.
Oh wait.
This is now an esports.
Oh wait they changed it.
So it's only this theater right in here.
Oh this used to be a thing up here too.
Okay never mind.
But yeah.
Twin box garage is a live house.
Where you can watch idols.
And sometimes even.
Thank you.
You'll see idols outside the station.
Outside Akihabara station.
And they'll be passing out flyers.
And this actually happened to me once.
Where I saw some idols.
And I was like you know what.
I'm never seen them before.
I'm going to go out of my comfort zone a little bit.
And so.
I um.
I asked them like who they were.
And they told me who they were.
And they were like yeah actually once.
Once a month we do a free show.
At akiba twin box.
And we're doing one tonight.
So if you come you can see our free show.
And I was like what that's so awesome.
Is there a show every night.
Not every night no.
It's not like a dedicated place like deer stage.
It's more like.
Specific events like you know.
Sometimes there's like.
Idol shows though.
Where it's like a bunch of idol groups.
It's called a taiban for those shows.
Where like you know.
15 groups will be performing but.
But yeah I went.
I went.
And I saw them.
And I was there with like.
5 other people.
And everyone was staring.
At the ghost girl.
Who clearly was out of place.
But um.
It was fun.
It was a lot of fun.
So.
Hello welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
I found a bunch of great idol groups doing that too.
Yeah so if you ever want to experience.
Like a true akiba idol show.
Twin box is a super awesome place to go to.
There's also over here akiba oh.
Another one.
Oh woah woah woah.
But I'm also going to introduce.
Uh.
One of my favorite maid cafes.
In Akihabara.
Right here.
Jam Akihabara.
So when you see the akiba oh.
When you see the twin box.
You're right here.
It's very easy to see.
Because of all the.
What's it called.
The landmarks.
I've mentioned jam before.
But jam akihabara is again.
Kind of like cure maid cafe.
Clap.
Please my drama.
Um.
It's like cure maid cafe.
Cure maid cafe.
Where.
I'm going mad that's for sure.
Where it's not like you're super high energy.
Like woohoo.
This is a maid cafe.
It's very like chill.
The girls are like.
They kind of give you your food.
They don't leave you alone.
Lots of people come here to like.
With their computers to like work on stuff.
It just feels like.
It's a cafe with maids essentially.
And so um.
They do also a lot of collabs with like.
With visual novels.
They've done collabs with vtubers.
So sometimes they have special menus.
They have special menus where it's like.
Specially made cocktails by the maids.
Um.
They have seasonal stuff.
Like they just have a lot.
And it's so chill.
It's like the perfect place to just kind of.
Go and wind down.
So after a busy day.
I'm almost always at Jam Akihabara.
If I'm not at Deer Stage.
So um.
A normal cafe but you get to see maids walking around.
Exactly.
What's the name of the cafe again?
Jam Akihabara.
Right here.
You can see it.
J-A-M.
So um.
Yeah.
It's super duper nice.
Like if you're not wanting the like.
Everything like that.
Everything it's just like.
It's so chill.
It's so nice.
Also what is this?
I keep seeing this.
Oh!
Akikaru.
Akikaru is a um.
It looks.
Is this?
Thank you.
Akikaru is a um.
Is a um.
Is a.
Magazine.
It's a free magazine.
Oh it's redo of healer.
Oh my god that's so funny.
Oh yeah you're right.
Um.
I love Jam.
Me too.
But Akikaru is a free magazine.
That you'll see across.
In certain places in Akihabara.
Where um.
They show.
It's just like an Akiba themed magazine.
They're free.
You can take them for free.
They have like.
Akikaru models and stuff.
And sometimes they do.
They do interviews with them.
Or they show off new anime.
Or new places in Akiba.
So um.
Yeah.
Uh.
That's not redo.
That's the animal slave girl one.
Oh it's not.
Oh wait.
I thought.
Okay.
It's so hard to read backwards.
I thought it said healer.
I have no idea.
I'm trusting whatever you guys say.
Hmm.
I don't know this one.
I don't know if it's even still there.
Maid cafes sometimes come and go so quickly.
Which is a little sad.
Because if you find one that you really like.
But Jam has been there forever.
Like a really long time.
Really really long time.
Here's uh.
So if you're confused where we are.
Here's Culture Zone.
This is the big big building.
There's Taito over there.
Meat mop.
And uh.
This is uh.
The Lost.
The used to be Dragon Quest Lost.
And this is a maid cafe building.
Um.
Mmm.
Meat mop.
There's always girls here advertising this place.
But I've never been.
It says it's a.
Maid cafe con cafe.
And it says for.
13 hours.
It's 2,000 yen.
Which is all you can drink.
Which I'm like.
Huh?
But there's always girls.
Advertising it right here.
They're always standing here with a big sign and stuff.
Another Akibao.
Welcome.
Many thanks.
Let's see.
So if you're.
Again if you're all turned around.
If you go down this way.
You'll get to UDX.
And you'll get to um.
The train station.
If you go down this way.
Which we are going to go down.
You'll get to Akibao Zettai Ryouiki.
I mean you can drink water.
So true.
The Nomihodai is the water.
There's some other maid cafes in here.
Wait.
In here too?
Oh no here here sorry.
There's some other maid cafes in here.
In here.
There's like a.
I think this is the Danso.
Not Danso.
I think this is.
It might be Danso.
It might be Danso or Ikemen.
I can't remember.
But there's an OL cafe down here as well.
So this is kind of like the.
Off the beaten path a little bit.
Can I go please?
There we go.
The back roads.
I'm so impressed.
By how much you know about Akibao.
So cute.
Stop it Maya stop it.
There's several places back here.
That I want to mention though.
Because they're really cool.
IMHO.
Why is everything closed?
I can't tell where the.
Everything is blocked by the cars.
I can't tell where anything is.
I can't tell you guys.
Where the OL cafe is.
I think it's somewhere back there.
I think I passed it but I couldn't see it.
Oh time travel.
Yeah we will in a second.
But before we time travel.
I kind of mentioned cat cafes before.
This one I like this cat cafe.
It's called Nekojalala.
It's pretty small.
But it's very cute.
The cats are.
I don't know.
I find it better than the really big open cat cafes.
Because.
Obviously you get more people in there.
So the cats are a little more tired.
Than cat cafes.
And also because they are bigger.
There is less chance of seeing a cat.
But here the cats are like everywhere.
They are like all over the place.
They are up.
They are down.
They are everywhere.
I recommend Nekojalala.
If you want to go to a cat cafe.
In Akihabara.
I have not heard anything bad about them.
So I hope.
I hope it's okay.
And so.
Sometimes when you are walking by.
You can see a cat in the window as well.
But it has a sign here.
It says don't tap on the glass.
Don't hurt the cats.
Continuing onward.
More concept cafe.
Maid cafe.
Perhaps.
I'm really.
Okay guys.
We will travel back in time.
To see if we can find the OL cafe too.
Sorry I forgot about it a little bit.
Because I got distracted by this.
Ta-da.
Hold on.
You can see the posters from here.
Ta-da.
This is a place called.
Mylish.
Which is another maid cafe.
Sorry I only know maid cafes.
But Mylish is special because.
This is the maid cafe.
Featured in Steins Gate.
Yeah.
This is the.
This is the Steins Gate cafe.
Actually I think it's this seat.
Or this seat right here.
Is where.
Where they sat.
In the show.
And there's even pictures of them sitting in those seats.
At the tables.
It's so so cute.
Yeah.
It's one of these.
It's one of these seats.
Yeah.
You can go here.
It's again.
It's a little more maid cafe than.
It's like in the middle.
Between like cure and jam.
And like maid dreaming and at home.
It's like just in that middle.
Where they still do a little bit of.
Like maid cafe fan service.
But they.
Don't perform here.
Um.
It's like a little chill.
But of course you have to go.
If you're a fan of Steins Gate.
They have like Steins Gate gachapon in there.
And this is such a good beginner's maid cafe.
Yeah.
That is a.
That is a good way to put it.
Have you been to Akiba Guild at all?
I have not.
Because to be honest I don't care so much about.
I mean.
I was worried that it was more bar than cafe.
You know.
Because I was like.
There's like the whole casino aspect and everything.
My buddy from KFP went there.
Oh nice.
What do you mean beginner?
Um.
Beginner in that like.
A maid cafe.
Like maid dreaming.
Or at home.
Or some of the other ones.
Might be a little overwhelming.
In terms of how the energy is.
But this one is a little more chill.
If you want to see.
If you just kind of enjoy the maid cafe vibe.
You know.
It's not too weird or overwhelming.
Yeah.
Yeah exactly.
It's pretty chill.
I'll be cringe and go as Okabe.
And cosplay.
It's not cringe at all.
In fact I'm sure people have done it before.
Yeah.
I started with maid dreaming.
That's okay too.
It's not bad.
Um.
It's not bad at all.
To start with maid dreaming.
But if you're looking.
If you're just like trying to ease someone into the maid cafe world.
You know.
This is a good one probably.
Um.
Is there a metal gear maid cafe?
Did you know there was a metal gear cafe in France?
Did you know?
That that existed?
In France?
Why?
It was like a pop up cafe.
I'm pretty sure it was France.
Yeah.
I think it was for MGS4.
No.
4 or 5.
Yeah.
It was somewhere in Europe.
It might have not been France but.
Yeah.
It was a special event.
No it's not there anymore.
It was just a pop up.
I'm so depressed.
But also I would have had to go to France.
Hahaha.
Um.
This place right next to it also.
Right next to Mileage is called.
It is still here right?
Uh.
It might be here.
Or it might be down here.
Thank you.
I like how when you're the tour guide.
Akiba appears to be oops all maids.
Hahaha.
Hey.
Can you.
I've talked about figure stores too.
I talked about.
I talked about those annoying clappers at.
Taito.
Genie store.
Thank you.
Um.
Made Dreaming and Anil has English menu software on their stuff.
Oh yes.
Made Dreaming and At Home also are very foreigner friendly.
Because they're like the two biggest in Akiba.
So they have a lot of good.
They have a lot of um.
Not only just usually maids.
At least some maids that speak a little bit of English.
Um.
But they also have English menu.
So.
But anyway.
This place is called.
Um.
And it says menu list.
But it's not the type of menu that you'd expect.
It's not a restaurant.
This is actually a hair salon.
Which is so cool.
It's a otaku themed hair salon.
Where if you're just like.
A hair cut like.
I don't know.
Kirito.
You can go and request your hair to be cut like.
An anime character.
You can tell them an anime character.
And be like I want.
I want Rem.
Blue hair color.
And they'll make it happen.
Can I get a Goku cut?
I can be Goku.
Yeah.
Let's get the Yu.
Oh my gosh.
Yugi.
But yeah.
So they kind of specialize in that.
And like on the inside.
You can't see.
Let me see if I can.
No.
It's still covered.
Oh yeah.
You can see here.
Like there's all this manga and everything on the walls.
Oh yeah.
You can see here.
The cut.
The color.
The head spa.
The treatment.
Yeah.
Hi Mylish.
Oh.
I don't think this hotomoto is here anymore.
Yeah.
Ugh.
But um.
Woo.
Those prices.
I'm gonna be honest.
These prices.
Are extremely.
Actually these are on the better side of Japan.
Not gonna lie.
This is from 2021 so.
I don't know if it's any different but.
This is really normal for.
Hair salon in Japan.
There are some cheaper ones.
There was one that's a chain.
I don't remember it.
But um.
Yeah.
5000 yen for a haircut.
Look.
You're getting the Goku.
What do you expect?
Sorry.
I'm finishing my drink.
I got some Thai tea earlier.
But yeah.
So if you're wondering.
Where the heck are we?
If you go down here.
Oh I'm gonna go back to 2023.
Cause things have changed.
If you go down here.
If you're here.
You're just like.
Where the heck are we?
I'll show you.
Please.
Take bigger steps please.
Look.
You can kinda read it.
There.
It's the Tam Tam.
That we were at before.
Gaptrox.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Can I have a Saitama haircut too?
Yeah you can.
Traffic is bad.
We're back at the Tam Tam.
So right there.
Is Suehirobashi.
And this is all Chuo-dori.
And then.
Down here.
Oh no.
Sorry.
Wrong street.
This is Culture Zone.
Down here is Culture Zone.
And this is Chubbymaid Cafe.
This is old lady.
Old lady.
The old lady Sasquatch.
Of Akihabara.
What's the idol landscape like now compared to say 10 to 15 years ago?
Do current idols look at 48 slash Hello Project Golden Era as a big deal?
Or is that now considered boomer tier?
Thanks for the tour.
Thanks for the question.
I...
I think now it is kind of boomer...
territory.
There's like a bunch of groups and heroines that are kind of the up and coming stuff.
Groups that are idols that are big on TikTok are kind of what's like taking over.
Because...
Um...
A lot of girls have been getting more into idols.
Especially like there's a group called iLife.
That's really popular.
They're part of heroines.
But I would say that yeah.
And also...
Kpop has influenced stuff a ton.
So...
So yeah.
Fruit Zipper.
Fruit Zipper is really big right now.
It is kind of like...
Not to say that there's not people that still admire Hello Project.
Because Hello Project is still a group and of course AKB is still a group and everything but...
Yeah...
The whole wave of chika idols that take after Ohmori Seiko are fun.
Yeah, yeah...
Um...
So... I don't know.
It's hard to say.
Times just grow and change.
That's all.
Exactly.
Exactly, exactly.
Hmm...
When I was in Japan last, I went to Tower Records.
And um...
As I was walking in, there was a big group of people and I was like, whoa, what's going on?
And there was AKB signing a big poster in the front of the store.
And I thought to myself, I was like, if this had been me...
Like...
If this had been me 10 years ago, I would have probably... I would have auto-conned it all over the floor.
I would have auto-conned all over the floor.
I would have been like...
Like...
I would have lost my mind.
But...
Um...
But I kind of was just like, oh, that's neat.
And then I went on my way.
Not a fan of that verb.
Don't say it like that!
But you know what I mean!
Anyway...
Well, I've skipped over a bunch of stuff, but I think this might be a good place to call it.
Um...
Oh wait, we were gonna go back in time for the...
For the...
Um...
The OL Cafe, maybe.
I've been actually quite tired because...
Um...
Okay, guys.
Announcement!
Actually, some of you already know this.
But that's okay, if you are on the Patreon.
I got a second cat!
I thought auto-conned meant the other thing he's known for doing.
Hm?
What's that?
Wait, actually...
Thank you, man.
No, thank you!
Yeah, I got another cat!
She's so cute!
I hadn't announced it sooner because I was kind of wanting to see how...
Um...
How Butaro reacted to her.
Um, but...
They're getting along-ish.
They're only hissing sometimes.
Um...
But I didn't want to say it sooner because I was like, what if she...
What if she doesn't get along with my cat and...
Um...
Then I have to like, you know...
What if it's like really bad to the point...
Mint, you already told us?
Not on stream!
Wait, I told you guys yesterday?
I did?
...
I told you yesterday?
You said you didn't want to say it, but you did.
...
Okay.
Well, okay.
Let me explain why I've been so tired then.
Because, do you know how exhausting?
It's been like taking care of like two babies.
Where like, I have to keep one cat in a separate room, and then another cat, and I let them go, and I let them... and I do stuff with them, and then also trying to get them to like each other, and...
I am pretty tired.
Okay, I'm gonna take tomorrow... Well, I'm not taking tomorrow off because I'm actually quite busy tomorrow, but...
Is the new cat just a kitten?
She's about one years old.
So... She's pretty kitten.
I'm so sorry.
When did I say that I told you guys?
When did I say?
A singular years old.
Kind of past the kitten age?
Yes, but...
Last night?
Yeah, but like when last night?
Gosh, I don't remember at all.
No, I know I did bunny garden yesterday, but I don't remember when I said it last night.
Someone asked about it?
Oh, when I was... That's probably why I don't remember because...
I...
Because I...
Because I was thinking of, you know... Because it was brought up as a super chat.
Okay, I remember.
I remember now!
I remember now.
Yeah, I said the new one wasn't stinky.
I remember.
I also have to remember that with bunny garden, my brain was entirely on the assets.
Wasn't yesterday mahjong?
Yeah, it was mahjong.
Now I'm confused.
You guys said... You guys are older than I am.
You guys said... You said bunny garden yesterday.
Yesterday was mahjong.
You guys said...
You guys are gaslighting me.
You guys said bunny garden.
Then it was two days ago.
We are tired too.
It was bunny garden because I missed yesterday.
Well, then there we go.
I was focused on the assets, okay?
And then mahjong made me leak through my ears.
So...
Okay, grandma.
Time for bed.
Shut up!
Thanks for the torment!
Always fun to see you gush over things you love.
Hope the new cat does well.
Thanks!
Thank you!
I hope that this was different enough from the last time that I did the tour so that, you know, you could see...
Hopefully hear some new things.
I mean, things have updated in Akihabara and the unfortunate thing is there's cars blocking the way.
But also, we don't have like you know, a 2024 map yet.
But next time I go, I will...
I will take some footage myself and I will share it with you guys.
Where is...
Where are the OLs?
Just giving the tour guide a tip.
I hope...
Oh!
A tip!
I thought you meant you were telling me like a...
Like a tip as in like...
Advice.
Thank you so much for the spooky super chat!
Hope to visit Akiba someday so I was taking notes.
Maybe I can go see the maid mint maid cafe.
I hope one day I can collab with the maid cafe.
That'd be crazy.
Maybe one day.
I gotta get bigger.
Maybe I gotta get bigger.
Where are we at?
2013.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I think 2022 is our best bet.
Cause it has moved around a little bit.
The OL cafe.
I'll find it.
Someday.
Here's a tip.
Don't quit your day job.
Ayo!
Here's an advice.
Take this tip.
Stop.
Ayo!
Who would quit their day job to stream?
That's so...
silly.
That's actually like the worst idea ever.
That's like...
Who would risk it all?
Who would risk it for the biscuit?
This is so much fun, you guys.
I thought I would have to cancel because my head has been hurting these past couple of days.
Probably because I've been just a little stressed out about the cats.
And just some other stuff too.
But...
You know.
I'm doing my best.
Going in October.
This gave me some great ideas on where to go.
Thanks, man.
Thanks, bro.
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait to hear all about it.
You can be the Anna Miller's mascot.
Because they're dead too.
Who's Anna Miller?
I'm going to Japan in September.
Thank you for the recs.
Yeah, of course.
Of course.
But...
Yes.
I'm going to rest tomorrow.
And hope you guys liked this tour.
Hopefully...
I'm glad if it gave you some recommendations.
Some ideas of how to get around Akihabara.
So when you go, you don't feel entirely lost or overwhelmed.
And...
Yeah.
Thank you for risking it.
Here's some money for the biscuits.
This tour was fun.
Thank you!
Yeah, we'll do a part 2.
Do you see the Kanda Myojin Muse stairs down here too?
Yes, it is!
Right here!
This is actually the stairs to...
Oh, that's a wall.
This is the stairs to Kanda Myojin.
The stairs that they go to in Love Live.
That they run up and down.
Thanks for reminding me.
What do you feed for your new kitty?
I don't really want to get into it because I've been a little stressed about it.
Basically, my...
My...
Butaro, he stopped eating.
When I took him to the vet, they were like, he's really healthy, but he's lost 2 pounds.
And so...
I was really stressed about that because he had...
I kept having to give him some medicine which would stress him out because he had something going on on his arm.
And so that was stressing him out.
And then stressing him out.
And then the new cat was stressing him out.
And then he was getting skinny.
And so he just wasn't eating a lot.
And so...
I've had to start cooking him chicken.
Like actual chicken.
For him to eat.
He won't eat anything else.
My spoiled cat.
But...
But uh...
Uh...
So...
Yeah, I was really stressed about that because I was...
I would just like sit there trying to get him to eat anything.
And I was just like sitting on the floor crying trying to get my cat to eat.
So...
Sorry if my brain is scattered.
It's just been...
And then I've been trying to...
Get my maid cafe ready for when Mataro visits.
So I've been trying to read and rearrange some stuff.
Um...
Yeah...
Anyway, sorry.
I didn't mean to bother you guys with all that.
I try not to...
I try not to show it on stream.
But if I'm scatterbrained because I'm stressed I'm really sorry.
Um...
But yeah.
I try not to show it on stream.
I try not to bother you guys with it.
So we can just have a fun time, right?
Um...
This tour was awesome!
I'm going to find this bot and mark down all the places I want to go to for my own trip.
Thank you, MeetMop!
Thank you, Tal!
MeetMop!
What are those stairs?
Your name?
No, no!
These are the stairs that lead up to Kanda Myojin.
The stairs in Love Live!
The stairs that they...
It's a different anime.
But look.
Kanda Myojin.
Wow!
The sakura!
Oh my gosh!
Hanami!
In my stream!
Wow!
Nice!
Extra snack funds for the kitty in the main.
Thank you.
Yeah, this is where...
Nozomi works in Love Live!
There's also...
Um...
There's also a lot of gochiusa...
What's the word?
The little things that you write your wishes on.
If you go to these...
Um...
There used to be a lot of love live and gochiusa.
Good tour.
100% spoiled kitty.
Yes, he is.
But um...
Yeah!
I'm going to go sleep now.
Actually, no.
I have some cleaning I need to do.
But...
Thank you guys.
Hold on.
I hope you enjoyed the tour.
Don't mind that I'm huge.
It's a perspective thing.
It's perspective.
I'm not a giant or anything.
I'm not going to crush these people or anything.
I'm not a giant.
Ah!
Splatter!
Cheese!
I can't help you.
Hold on.
I don't want to look like a nerd.
Cheese!
Thank you guys!
This is where we'll end the tour.
This is where, we will end the tour for today.
For now.
Until I have more places to recommend you.
The next time I go.
This is a nice spot and the...
Mm hmm...
It's a beautiful sunny day.
The flowers are blooming.
My allergies are acting up.
Um...
I went to a chika idol taiban in Kanda Myojin Culture Center back during my first trip here in December.
Free cheki is so good.
Yeah, a lot of groups have been doing the free cheki thing for the first time you see it.
For the first time you see them.
The live stream was so much fun!
Thank you BashaMins!
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
Like I said, we'll do a part 2.
Bless you.
Thank you!
Hope you enjoyed it.
I don't know why I'm struggling to end this.
Maybe because I feel like I have so much more I could talk about.
Next time.
Your passion lifts my spirits.
Okay, I really need to go to sleep.
Thank you everyone!
Bye bye!
See you!
Not tomorrow.
Sunday!
Bye bye!
Oh, it's
heavy!
Oh, it's heavy!
Bye bye!